MY NAME IS SARA MARIE
AND I'M AUDITIONING FOR
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I REALLY THINK I COULD
BE AN AWESOME MODEL.
HI, WHAT'S UP?
I'M TYRA BANKS AND
I'M GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WELCOME TO INGLEWOOD.
MAKE ME AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
PLEASE, PLEASE,
PLEASE, PLEASE.
I HOPE YOU LIKE ME,
'CAUSE I KNOW
I'D BE GOOD FOR YOU.
MISS J., I CAN
WALK AND...
YO, I KNOW
I AIN'T PERFECT.
I KNOW YOU CAN TEACH ME
A LITTLE SOMETHIN',
OR MAYBE
I CAN TEACH YOU.
HOLLA.
HEY, GUYS, IT'S NICOLE.
I WOULD MAKE
A REALLY GREAT
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I AM THE
NEXT COVER GIRL.
EASY, BREEZY,
BANKS, EASY.
WHY I SHOULD BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL?
I CAN DANCE.
GET CRUNK DANCE...
I CAN DO THAT....
I'M 22 YEARS OLD.
MEANS MY BIRTHDAY
IS 1983.
'81.
'84.
OH, I CAN BOX.
OH, NO, YOU DIDN'T!
♪♪♪
I HAVE COMPETED IN
BEAUTY PAGEANTS BEFORE,
AND MY COMMUNICATIONS
EXPERT ALWAYS TELLS ME,
"DON'T WORRY ABOUT
THE COMPETITION.
YOU'RE HERE FOR YOU."
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME
LEAVING THE STATE.
I WAS ALL CRYING, AND MY
FACE WAS ASHY FROM TEARS.
I AM NOT HERE TO WIN
THIS COMPETITION.
I AM THIS COMPETITION.
"TOP MODEL,"
HERE I AM, NUMBER ONE.
IT'S ALL ABOUT ME,
BABY.
I HAVE A LOT
OF ACQUAINTANCES,
BUT I HAVE NO FRIENDS,
AND I DON'T REALLY
CARE, ACTUALLY.
WELL, YEAH, I DO.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHT, READY?
ONE, TWO, THREE.
OH, YOU GUYS NEED
TO WORK OUT.
(chattering)
HI. I'M MELISSA.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
(greeting)
I'M SIZING UP
MY COMPETITION.
I'M LOOKING AROUND,
SCOPING EACH GIRL,
TRYING TO SEE,
AND THESE GIRLS
ARE JUST GORGEOUS.
OF COURSE,
I'M INTIMIDATED.
DON'T GET ME TWISTED.
HEY, EVERYBODY.
GIRLS!
(squealing)
THANKS FOR COMING TO L.A.
YOU GUYS ARE IN
BEVERLY HILLS, CALIFORNIA.
(cheering)
AT THE FAMOUS BEVERLY
HILTON HOTEL.
THIS IS WHERE
ALL THE STARS COME.
YEAH!
SO YOU GUYS ALL
PROBABLY KNOW WHO I AM,
BUT I'M JAY MANUEL
AND I'M THE
CREATIVE DIRECTOR OF
ALL OF THE PHOTO SHOOTS
HERE ON "TOP MODEL."
ARE YOU GUYS READY
TO WORK HARD?
YES!
WE GOT A LOT
OF WORK TO DO.
IF YOU WANT TO BE
AT THE TOP OF YOUR GAME,
YOU NEED TO LIVE,
BREATHE, EAT, SLEEP
THIS BUSINESS.
THAT'S HOW TYRA DID IT,
AND THAT'S HOW ONE OF YOU
ARE GONNA DO IT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE COMBED THIS
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF GIRLS
SHOWED UP.
BUT YOU 36 ARE STILL
IN THE RUNNING TO BE WHAT?
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL!
THIS IS AMAZING.
I ALMOST PEED MYSELF.
(laughs)
♪♪♪
GOOD MORNING.
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS A LITTLE CHALLENGE
THIS MORNING, OKAY?
IT'S GOING TO BE
ABOUT POSING.
NOW, IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND POSING,
BECAUSE THE CLIENT,
A PHOTOGRAPHER,
AN ART DIRECTOR,
MIGHT GIVE
YOU A SPECIFIC REFERENCE,
AND IF YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS,
THEN THAT'S NOT GONNA HELP
YOU OR HELP THE JOB.
SO I DECIDED I HAD TO GO
GET SOMEBODY TO HELP ME
JUDGE THIS LITTLE
COMPETITION
HERE THIS MORNING.
MISS THING,
COME ON OUT HERE.
♪♪♪
(cheering)
WHAT'S UP, GIRLS?
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
RUNWAY DIVA
EXTRAORDINAIRE.
SO LET'S BRING YOU UP
TWO BY TWO.
(cheering)
WHY DON'T YOU GUYS
GIVE US SUPERMODEL SEXY?
♪♪♪
SO WE HAVE SUPERMODEL,
VERY MASCULINE SEXY
ON THE RIGHT,
AND VERY SEXY
SULTRY ON THE LEFT.
SO GIVE US SUPERMODEL
EDGY.
KAY, NOW I'M
GONNA ACTUALLY
GIVE YOU A MODEL
REFERENCE.
GIVE US
LINDA EVANGELISTA.
♪♪♪
ADRIANA LIMA.
YOU THINK ANY
OF THEM CAN
GIVE YOU
MISS GISELLE BUNDCHEN?
♪♪♪
IT'S HARD TO GET
A GOOD POSE
'CAUSE WHEN
I RELAX MY FACE,
EVERYONE THINKS I'M
PISSED OR SAD.
WE WANT YOU
TO GIVE US YOUR
FIERCEST POSE ON
THE PLANET.
THAT'S A
TYRA BANKS POSE.
GIVE US A TYRA
BANKS POSE.
THE REAL
TYRA BANKS POSE.
THAT AIN'T
NO TYRA BANKS POSE!
(cheering)
I'VE NEVER BEEN AROUND
A CELEBRITY IN MY LIFE
OR ANYONE LIKE THAT,
AND IT'S, LIKE,
NOT JUST A
LITTLE CELEBRITY,
IT'S TYRA BANKS.
(cheers and applause)
I'M EMBRACING TYRA,
AND SHE'S EMBRACING ME,
AND I'M GOING
ABSOLUTELY CRAZY.
ISN'T SHE GORGEOUS?
SHE'S FIERCE.
THIS IS THE PRETTY ONE
RIGHT HERE.
ALL YOU GUYS KNOW THIS IS
GONNA BE A CRAZY WEEK, RIGHT?
LOOK TO YOUR LEFT AND LOOK
TO YOUR RIGHT
AND LOOK AT
YOUR COMPETITION.
NOW, YOU MAY SEE
GIRLS THAT ARE
MORE BEAUTIFUL THAN YOU.
THE PRETTIEST GIRL DOESN'T
NECESSARILY ALWAYS MAKE IT,
OR THE EDGIEST GIRL DOESN'T
BUT THE WINNER ALWAYS
HAS SOMETHING
THAT'S EXTRA SPECIAL.
SO THAT'S WHAT
I'M LOOKING FOR.
I'M LOOKING FOR GIRLS
THAT JUST ARE LIKE,
"TYRA, HERE I AM.
I'M BETTER THAN THIS
BITCH RIGHT NEXT TO ME."
(cheering)
YOU GUYS READY FOR
THIS AMAZING WEEK?
ALL RIGHT, I'LL SEE YOU
GUYS LATER!
BYE!
(cheering)
TYRA BANKS, YOU KNOW,
THIS CAN'T BE REAL.
I'M SCREAMING
IN MY HEAD.
I'M LIKE, "AAH, YOU
SERIOUS, OH, MY GOD!"
♪♪♪
COME ON IN.
MY NAME IS BRITTNEY.
BUT PEOPLE CALL
ME BRE,
AND I'M FROM
HARLEM, NEW YORK.
WHERE ABOUT
IN HARLEM?
YOU KNOW HARLEM?
YES, OF COURSE,
I'M FROM THE BRONX.
WELL, I'M SORRY
TO HEAR THAT.
WHY DO YOU SAY THE
MENTALITY OF HARLEM SUCKS?
WELL, SOME PEOPLE FEEL AS
THOUGH, IF YOU ARE AROUND
PEOPLE WHO ARE POOR
AND EVERYBODY AROUND YOU
IS POOR, THEN IT'S OKAY.
NOBODY WANTS TO GO
AND VENTURE OUT.
NOBODY WANTS TO GO AROUND
AND EXPLORE ANYTHING ELSE,
LIKE HARLEM IS IT.
YOU SAY THAT YOU'RE MESSY,
AND YOU DON'T TAKE BATHS
SOMETIMES BECAUSE
YOU'RE LAZY?
OKAY.
GIRL, LET ME SMELL
THAT, WAIT A MINUTE.
OH, NO, HE'S SERIOUS.
YOU DON'T KNOW.
HOLD ON,
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
OKAY, I'M GOOD.
POWDER FRESH MIXED
WITH...
(sniffing) MUSK.
(laughter)
I STAND UP FOR MYSELF
AND I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
SPEAKING UP AT ALL.
- THANK YOU, GUYS.
- BYE.
SHE'S SPUNKY.
YEAH.
(inhales deeply)
SHE IS FUNKY.
SPUNKY.
HI.
HOW ARE YOU?
I'M KYLE.
I'M 19 YEARS OLD AND
I AM FROM DEXTER, MICHIGAN.
HERE YOU GO.
THIS IS MY TOWN,
THE WHOLE TWO BLOCKS
OF DEXTER, MICHIGAN.
NO, IT'S NICE TO KNOW
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
EVERYONE I WALK BY IN
THE STREET, I KNOW THEM.
YOU WORK AT A
DAIRY QUEEN?
I WORK AT DAIRY QUEEN.
I LOVE IT.
HI, AND WELCOME
TO THE DEXTER DAIRY QUEEN.
CAN I TAKE YOUR ORDER?
I HONESTLY LIVE A VERY
NORMAL LIFE.
YOU KNOW, I CAN SAY THAT
I HAVE A GREAT FAMILY,
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE
THING THAT SETS ME
APART FROM OTHER GIRLS,
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN ABUSED,
THEY HAVE KIDS.
I MET A GIRL, KIM.
SHE'S A LESBIAN.
I'VE JUST NEVER MET
A LESBIAN BEFORE.
YOU HAVE, YOU JUST
DON'T KNOW THAT THEY WERE.
I'M VERY OPEN-MINDED.
I'VE NEVER BEEN A PERSON
TO NOT BE NICE TO ANYONE.
YOU KNOW, I'M ALWAYS
THE NICE GIRL.
HELLO.
HI.
HEY, GUYS.
I GO TO SCHOOL
AT WESLEYAN UNIVERSITY,
WHICH IS IN CONNECTICUT.
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
LIKE, I THINK I CAN BRING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT
TO MODELING.
I'VE GOT A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF A,
I DON'T WANT TO SAY
MASCULINE,
BUT I MIGHT AS WELL,
MASCULINE LOOK.
- WHATEVER.
- JUST SAY IT.
I WANT TO BE OUT.
LIKE, I'M GAY AND I, UM,
I'M REALLY PROUD OF IT.
I THINK THERE'S A CERTAIN
THING OF BEING PROUD.
LIKE, I'M BLACK AND PROUD,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
BUT I'M NOT, LIKE,
WALKING DOWN THE RED CARPET.
"I'M BLACK, I'M BLACK,"
YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M SAYING?
NOT, I'M CERTAINLY
NOT GONNA, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
WALK DOWN THE RED CARPET
AND TRY TO KISS GIRLS
ON THE WAY, YOU KNOW?
THAT'S, LIKE, NOT
WHAT I'M GONNA DO.
I KNOW THAT, LIKE, I HAVE
OFFENDED PEOPLE IN THE PAST.
I NEED TO LEARN THAT
NOT EVERYTHING
NEEDS TO BE EXPRESSED.
STRIKE A POSE.
LIKE, WHATEVER POSE
YOU WANT IN THAT SWIMSUIT.
ARE WE PLAYING FOOTBALL?
THAT WAS LIKE...
"ONE, TWO, THREE."
AND YOU KNOW THAT'S ABOUT
AS MUCH FOOTBALL I PLAYED.
HI!
- HOW ARE YOU?
- GOOD.
I WAS RAISED
A JEHOVAH'S WITNESS,
AND I HAVE STRAYED FROM,
YOU KNOW,
A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT I SHOULD
AND SHOULDN'T BE DOING.
I'M A HORRIBLE EXAMPLE
OF WHAT A JEHOVAH'S WITNESS
IS SUPPOSED TO BE LIKE.
WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN
DOING THAT'S BAD?
I'M A FORNICATOR,
I'M A SMOKER,
I CURSE LIKE A SAILOR
AND I DON'T GO
TO CHURCH.
I DEFINITELY STILL BELIEVE
IN THE RELIGION
THAT I WAS
BROUGHT UP IN.
I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET EVERYTHING
OUT OF MY SYSTEM
RIGHT NOW.
OKAY, SO YOU'RE ON THE
JEHOVAH'S LAYAWAY PLAN.
YES, THAT'S IT.
BUY NOW AND
PRAY LATER.
OH, MY GOD!
HELLO, HELLO, HELLO!
HEY.
TYRA, YOU LOOK
BEAUTIFUL.
HI, GUYS.
ME AND MY MOM DON'T GET
ALONG THAT WELL.
WE KIND OF HAVE, LIKE,
THE MOTHER-DAUGHTER
FEUD GOING ON.
NICOLE, WHY ARE YOU
SUCH A JEALOUS PERSON?
WELL, I'M A LITTLE BIT
JEALOUS OF MY SISTER.
BY MY MOM'S STANDARDS,
SHE'S A PERFECT CHILD.
YOU THINK IF
YOUR SISTER TRIED OUT FOR
"AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL,"
SHE WOULD HAVE MADE IT?
FIRST OF ALL,
SHE'S NOT AS CUTE AS ME.
NOT TO BE RUDE OR ANYTHING,
BUT SHE'S NOT.
AND SHE DOESN'T HAVE
A PERSONALITY LIKE MINE.
SEE?
I JUST WISH MY MOM COULD
SEE THAT.
I DO.
SHE'S SEEING
HOW FAR YOU GOT.
THERE ARE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF GIRLS
WHO TRIED OUT FOR THIS,
AND I PERSONALLY CHOSE YOU.
I HATE BEING
THE OLDEST.
I'VE HAD TO BREAK MY
PARENTS IN FOR EVERYTHING.
IT'S BEEN HELL.
STOMP ON ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT DON'T THINK
THAT YOU'RE GOOD ENOUGH.
- ALL RIGHT.
- I REALLY WANT THIS.
I'LL DO ANYTHING.
I'LL GET ON
MY KNEES AND BEG.
I'M SERIOUS, I WANT THIS
MORE THAN I'VE EVER WANTED
ANYTHING IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE.
DON'T EVER, EVER SAY
YOU'LL DO ANYTHING.
SAY YOU'LL
DO EVERYTHING,
AND THEN THEY SAY, LAY
ON THIS COUCH.
"OH, NO, HONEY,
NO, I AIN'T DOING THAT."
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
- I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
- THANK YOU.
I'M JUST SO EXCITED
TO BE HERE.
I WON'T COMPLAIN
ABOUT ANYTHING.
I SWEAR, WITH HER EARS
AND THE SHAPE OF HER HEAD,
I THOUGHT SHE WAS ONE OF
THE SEVEN DWARFS.
I SWEAR TO GOD.
SHE CAME CLOSER,
I SAID, "MODEL."
♪♪♪
WE NEED TO GO
TO THE CHAPSTICK AISLE.
WE NEED TO ALL GO TO THE
CHAPSTICK AISLE TOGETHER
BECAUSE I NEED TO GET
SOME CHAPSTICK.
WELL, YOU CAN
GET THAT RIGHT AT CHECK-OUT.
NO, WE CAN'T.
- IT'S IN AISLE 7.
- BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE IT IS.
I NEEDED TO
GET SOME CHAPSTICK.
EVERYONE ELSE, LIKE, KINDA
FREAKED OUT WHEN I SAID
I NEEDED THE CHAPSTICK
AND GOT ALL MAD ABOUT IT.
IS THERE CHAPSTICK
HERE?
DO YOU GUYS
HAVE ANY CHAPSTICK HERE?
WHY ARE WE HERE?
NICOLE HAD BEEN COMPLAINING
AND COMPLAINING.
SHE COMPLAINS
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
IT'S JUST HER NATURE.
IT'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH IT.
LIKE--YES, IT IS.
EXCUSE ME,
WHY ARE WE HERE?
WE NEED CHAPSTICK.
CHAPSTICK, AND WE NEED IT.
LET'S DO THAT
LAST, THOUGH.
LET'S JUST MAKE
SURE EVERYTHING
- IS ON OUR LIST FIRST.
- WE DON'T HAVE CHAP--
NO, LISTEN, WHAT
I'M SAYING IS,
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH GETTING CHAPSTICK.
LET'S MAKE SURE EVERYTHING
IS ON OUR LIST
AND THEN DO THAT LAST.
IF NICOLE KEEPS UP HER WHINING
AND MAKES IT IN THE HOUSE,
SERIOUSLY, I'M GONNA
STUFF HER IN A CLOSET
AND LEAVE HER THERE.
FIVE, SIX,
SEVEN, EIGHT.
ONE, TWO, ONE, TWO,
THREE, KICK.
BACK, TWO, THREE, KICK.
CROSS IT OVER, LADIES.
HELLO, HELLO, HELLO.
HELLO, HELLO,
HELLO TO YOU, TOO.
WHY DO YOU WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
AND NOT BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO BE LIKE TYRA BANKS.
- WE HEAR THAT ALL THE TIME.
- WHO DOESN'T WANT
TO BE LIKE TYRA BANKS?
IT'S JUST SOMETHING
I JUST KNOW
THAT I'M HERE TO DO.
THE ONLY PERSON TO ME
WHO I NEED IS ME
BECAUSE THAT'S
WHO I'VE HAD,
AND YOU KNOW, MY MOM FOR
A SHOULDER TO CRY ON,
BUT STILL AT THE
END OF THE DAY,
THE ONLY PERSON
I HAVE IS MYSELF.
IS THAT A MOHAWK
OR ARE YOU
SLICKED BACK
ON THE SIDES?
UM, I'M SLICKED BACK
ON THE SIDES.
OH, OKAY,
CAN YOU TAKE IT OFF?
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
I'M GETTING
A NAIMA KIND OF THING.
MAYBE WHEN SHE COMES BACK
WITH HER BATHING SUIT.
CAN YOU HAVE YOUR
HAIR ALL OUT
- WITH YOUR BATHING SUIT?
- YEAH, I CAN DO THAT.
SO WHY DON'T YOU GO
GIVE US SOME HAIR
AND GIVE US SOME BODY?
I HAD, LIKE, THE
CHEAPEST SWIMSUIT ON.
IT DOESN'T STAY
ON YOUR BUTT,
SO THEN WHEN
I HAD TO DO, LIKE,
THE CATWALK OUT
THE ROOM...
DIG OUT THE
MURPHY IN THE BOOTY.
JUST IN MY BUTT,
LIKE, ALL THE WAY
IN THE CRACK,
BUT I MEAN,
IT WASN'T TOO BAD.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT SHE'S
NOT TYPICALLY BEAUTIFUL.
LIKE, HER NOSE IS KIND
OF TOUCHING HER TOP LIP.
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
HOW ARE Y'ALL TODAY?
I LOVE
THE GLASSES REVEAL.
WHAT WAS THAT?
MMM, THAT'S TO
SHOW YOU ALL
THAT I COULD
DO IT BOTH WAYS.
I LIKE YOUR ACCENT.
THANK YOU.
WHAT'S YOUR
NATIONALITY?
- PUERTO RICAN.
- OKAY.
PUERTO RICAN.
I'M CURRENTLY A CRIMINAL
DEFENSE INVESTIGATOR.
I WORK FOR THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE.
WHERE I'VE WORKED
AS AN INVESTIGATOR
FOR APPROXIMATELY
TWO YEARS.
THIS IS MY OFFICE.
TELL US ABOUT
YOUR JOB.
MY DUTIES
IN THAT DEPARTMENT
IS GATHERING ALL TYPES
OF INVESTIGATIONS
THAT ATTORNEYS MAY
NEED, AND LET'S SAY,
"GO GET BOOBOO
AND ACROSS THIS CORNER
ON 36th STREET.
HE IS TALL
WITH A BIG GOLD CHAIN."
SO HERE GO D., ME.
GOING TO GET BOOBOO.
"YO, DO YOU KNOW WHERE
I CAN FIND BOOBOO?"
I MEAN, THEY
SEND ME TO THE HOOD.
I HAVE CURVES.
I HAVE HIPS.
YOU KNOW, I KNOW BEING
A PLUS SIZE MODEL
IS NOT GONNA BE EASY,
BUT THERE'S NO
COMPETITION IN MY EYES.
IT'S ME, AND I'M
FOCUSED.
AND WHEN I FOCUS,
ANY OBSTACLE THAT GETS
IN MY WAY, YOU'RE
ABOUT TO BE
RUNNED OVER BY BIG D.
GIVE ME SOME SPANISH
BEFORE YOU LEAVE.
THANK YOU.
GRACIAS.
I MEAN, HER BODY
PROPORTIONS
SEEM GREAT
FOR A PLUS SIZE MODEL.
♪♪♪
HELLO.
- YEAH.
- HOW ARE YOU?
YOU LOOK SO
PERKY AND HAPPY,
- AND, LIKE--
- I AM.
TENNIS, AND...
SO YOU SAY
THAT ACTUALLY YOU HAD
BREAST CANCER?
THIS WHOLE SIDE
WAS JUST LUMPS,
BASICALLY, MADE
UP OF LUMPS,
SO, I MEAN,
THEY TOOK IT ALL OUT.
I HAVE A HISTORY OF CANCER
IN MY FAMILY.
I WAS ALL FREAKING OUT,
THINKING I HAD IT, AND I JUST
GOT THE RESULTS BACK,
AND IT WAS BENIGN.
THAT'S GREAT.
I'M MISSING HALF
A BREAST,
BUT IT'S OKAY.
IT'S ALL WORTH IT.
IT DOESN'T
MAKE ME FEEL TOO BAD.
IN THE BEGINNING,
I WAS LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD,
YOU'RE TAKING MY LAST,
LIKE, WHAT I HAVE,
MY NUB."
OKAY, NOW I WANT
YOU TO WORK IT LIKE,
"YEAH, BABY, I'M FINE."
WORK IT,
WORK IT, WORK IT.
WORK IT!
I'M NOT FEELING IT.
(yodeling music playing)
SO YOU GOT WORK
TO DO.
HI.
SO YOU SAID
YOU DESCRIBE YOURSELF
AS A TEXAS BEAUTY QUEEN.
I SURE AM.
I'M BORN AND RAISED IN TEXAS
MY WHOLE LIFE.
EVERYWHERE I GO,
I'M LIKE, "I'M FROM TEXAS,"
AND I AM A BEAUTY
QUEEN, TOO,
AND TEXAS IS BY FAR
THE MOST COMPETITIVE STATE.
BEING IN PAGEANTS
I HAVE WORKED
WITH HAIR
AND MAKEUP ARTISTS,
AND I'M REALLY EASY
TO WORK WITH,
AND I THINK THAT
THE PHOTOGRAPHERS
AND MAKEUP ARTISTS
WOULD LOVE ME BECAUSE
I WILL DO WHAT
YOU TELL ME.
WHO'S MISS U.S.A.
RIGHT NOW?
SHE WAS NORTH CAROLINA.
AND WHAT COUNTRY
IS MISS UNIVERSE?
- AUSTRALIA.
NAME THREE COVER GIRLS
RIGHT NOW.
OKAY.
(crickets chirping)
I JUST--
THEIR NAMES JUST--
WHY DID I ASK
YOU THAT?
TO SEE WHETHER I'M MORE
DEDICATED TO
PAGEANTS OR MODELING.
AND WHAT DO YOU
THINK YOUR ANSWERS SHOW?
IT SOUNDED LIKE
I WAS MORE
DEDICATED TO PAGEANTS
THAN MODELING.
IT SURE DID.
BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
THOUGH.
- SHE'S PRETTY.
- BEAUTIFUL PRESENCE.
HI! HOW ARE YOU
GUYS DOING?
- I'M LIKE, RUNNING.
- OOH.
I REALLY HAVE
A POSSIBILITY
TO BE A MODEL VERSUS
BEHIND THE SCENES FASHION
AND, YOU KNOW, THE HAIR
AND THE MAKEUP.
I'M A BUYER
FOR A BOUTIQUE.
I LOVE TO LOOK
AT FASHION.
I LOVE TO
TRAVEL, AND I LOVE
TO BE IN FRONT OF
THE CAMERA.
I'M SUCH
A HAM, YOU KNOW?
YOU SAY YOU'RE A BUYER
FOR A BOUTIQUE
AND YOU LOVE LOOKING
AT FASHION MAGAZINES.
CAN YOU JUST RATTLE OFF
A FEW DESIGNERS
THAT YOU JUST LOVE?
MICHAEL KORS IS
ABSOLUTELY MY FAVORITE.
I THINK HE DOES SOME
OF THE GREATEST WHITES
I'VE EVER SEEN.
CHRISTIAN DIOR,
I THINK ABSOLUTELY AMAZING,
CHANEL.
THE NEWEST ARTIST I LIKE
THE BEST IS SARI PACINI.
I SEE CHARLIZE THERON
MEETS SHARON STONE.
HAVE PEOPLE
TOLD YOU THAT?
MY MOM, WE HAVE
WHAT WE CALL
A "PRETTY GENE"
IN MY FAMILY.
WE ALL HAVE THAT, TOO.
I HAVE MILKY SKIN
THAT ALLOWS FOR ME TO WEAR
LOTS OF DIFFERENT
COLORS HAIR.
YOU KNOW, IT'S A VERY
PINKY-OLIVE UNDERTONE.
I JUST HAVE A LOT OF THINGS
WORKING FOR ME
THAT MAKE THIS THE
RIGHT THING FOR ME TO DO.
NO, OKAY, YOU'RE
IN A PAGEANT,
AND I'M GONNA
QUESTION YOU, OKAY?
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
PRESIDENT BUSH
BEING DUMB
AND FROM TEXAS?
(laughter)
I DON'T THINK
HE'S DUMB.
OKAY, SINCE YOU ARE
SYMBOLIZING TEXAS,
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT YOU
SHOULD WIN THIS PAGEANT?
I THINK I REPRESENT
A LOT OF THINGS THAT
TEXAS HAS TO OFFER.
AT FIRST,
I WAS LIKE, "OH, GOD,
CASSANDRA'S SO ANNOYING."
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT,
IT'S FUNNY AT THIS POINT.
SHE TOTALLY EMBRACES IT.
SHE'S LIKE,
"YEAH, I AM ANNOYING."
SO WHAT'S UP WITH THIS
PERSONAL STYLE OF YOURS?
I LIKE IT,
IT'S KIND OF FUNKY.
I LIKE MAKEUP.
I LIKE DARK EYES.
I LOVE MY EYES.
IT'S THE ONLY MAKEUP
I WEAR.
AND I USED TO BE TOTAL
PUNK ROCK IN HIGH SCHOOL.
I CAN'T
SEE YOUR EYES
WITH ALL THAT MAKEUP
ON YOUR EYES.
- THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
- CAN YOU PEEL THEM OFF?
JUST COME ON,
RIP 'EM OFF.
OH, NO.
THEY ARE SO LONG.
THESE ARE HUGE.
THEY'RE TOO LONG.
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME
TO TAKE OFF?
GO WASH THAT FACE.
- EVERYTHING?
- YES.
NO EYE LINER.
- JUST MASCARA.
- NO EYE SHADOW.
WHO'S THIS?
I'M NAKED.
THE NATURAL BEAUTY.
LOOK AT YOU.
NOW YOU LOOK LIKE A MODEL
IN THE MAKING, POSSIBLY.
I KNOW THAT I'M A PRETTY
GIRL WITHOUT MAKEUP,
BUT MAKEUP
IS JUST AWESOME.
BUT I'M NOT AS
CONFIDENT AS I WAS BEFORE.
HI.
MY NAME IS LISA.
I AM 24 YEARS OLD
AND I AM FROM LOS ANGELES,
CALIFORNIA.
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS TO ME,
I APPRECIATE IT,
EVEN IF IT'S LIKE
THE SMALLEST LITTLE THING.
I GET EXCITED
OVER, LIKE,
THE STUPIDEST GOOD THINGS
THAT HAPPEN TO ME.
SO WHAT'S THIS ABOUT
YOUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH YOUR MOM?
MY MOM--SHE NEVER HAD ANY,
LIKE, MATERNAL INSTINCTS,
AND SHE DIDN'T
LIKE BUYING US STUFF.
SHE JUST, LIKE,
SHE WAS--
I'M SORRY, BUT SHE
WAS REALLY SELFISH,
AND I THINK SHE HAS
SO MUCH FRUSTRATION
INSIDE OF HER.
WHEN I DID SOMETHING,
LIKE,
SMALL OR WRONG,
IT WAS LIKE, HUGE.
LIKE, SHE JUST, LIKE,
TOOK IT OUT ON ME HARDCORE.
I REMEMBER, I WOULD
ALWAYS JUST BE LIKE,
"WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING TO ME?"
AND I, LIKE, I
WOULD PRAY.
I KNEW AT THAT MOMENT THAT
I WASN'T A BAD PERSON
AND I KNEW THAT I
DIDN'T DESERVE THAT.
AAAAH!
YOU SEEM LIKE YOU RECEIVED
A LOT OF CRITICISM
FROM YOUR MOM
AND A LOT OF,
"YOU'RE NOT GOOD ENOUGH."
YOU'RE GONNA BE IN FRONT
OF JUDGES EVERY WEEK
- TELLING YOU THINGS
- I KNOW.
VERY SIMILAR TO THAT.
"YOU'RE NOT GOOD ENOUGH,
YOU NEED TO DO BETTER,
- THIS IS BAD."
- LET ME TELL YOU ONE THING.
I'VE GOT IT FROM
THE WORST.
I GOT IT
FROM MY MOTHER.
I HAVE LEARNED TO
HAVE THE STRENGTH
INSIDE OF MYSELF.
I AM THE STRONGEST
PERSON IN THIS WHOLE THING.
I HAVE DEALT WITH EVERYTHING
THAT COULD BE
THROWN MY
WAY ALL AT ONCE,
SO NO ONE'S GONNA
STOP ME.
I ADMIRE
YOU RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE YOU ARE GIVING
YOUR ALL.
YOU'RE GIVING EVERYTHING
INSIDE OF YOURSELF
AND REALLY SHOWING US EXACTLY
WHO YOU ARE, AND I THINK
- THAT'S REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
- THANK YOU.
I THINK MY HEART IS TOO
BIG FOR ME SOMETIMES,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
THAT MAKES ME WHO I AM.
♪♪♪
WORK IT,
WORK IT, WORK IT.
I'M IN LOVE WITH
THIS GIRL.
I THINK SHE'S THE SWEETEST
THING IN THE WORLD.
♪♪♪
WE GOT TURKEY AND HAM
AND PEANUT BUTTER
AND JELLY.
TOP RAMEN?
THE HOT WATER
IS BEHIND YOU.
I DON'T THINK
THAT THIS WORKS.
THIS IS LIKE THE BEST PART
OF THE DAY,
I'M, "NOM NOM."
THIS RAMEN
TASTES LIKE HAY.
IT TASTES LIKE HAY.
LIKE STRAW HAY.
IT'S REALLY BAD.
NO, IT'S BAD.
THAT'S WHY I'M
COMPLAINING.
I MADE IT WRONG.
HOW MUCH WRONG?
SHE MADE THIS
CUP OF NOODLES WRONG.
HOW WAS THAT
COMPLAINING?
IF I'M TELLING
YOU ABOUT--
NO, NICOLE,
YOU HAVE BEEN COMPLAINING
THE WHOLE TIME.
JUST GIVE ME
FIVE MINUTES
WITHOUT IT,
JUST FIVE, PLEASE.
I'M SORRY, I'M GHETTO.
I CAN COOK MY
CUP OF NOODLES REAL GOOD.
LIKE, YOU CAN'T
GET MAD AT ME
FOR THAT--FOR
NOT KNOWING HOW
TO MAKE RAMEN NOODLES.
SERIOUSLY.
YOU'VE BEEN
COMPLAINING ABOUT COFFEE.
YOU'VE BEEN COMPLAINING
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
SO THIRSTY.
I THINK I'M GONNA DIE!
YOU HAVE BEEN
COMPLAINING...
THE BEAUTY BUSINESS CAN
BE QUITE UGLY,
BECAUSE OF HOW
CATTY PEOPLE GET.
NO, IT'S YOU WHO WAS
COMPLAINING ABOUT CHIPS...
GIRLS ARE STARTING TO
GET BITCHY AND LIKE,
COMPETITIVE AND,
LIKE, DRAMATIC.
WE'RE CONSTANTLY HEARING
NICOLE COMPLAIN.
YOU DON'T
EVEN KNOW ME.
HOW COULD YOU SAY THAT
I'M SPOILED?
WHO WANTS A COOKIE?
APPARENTLY SOME
OF THE GIRLS
THINK I WAS
COMPLAINING.
I GUESS I DIDN'T
SEE THAT.
I'M NOT REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT THEM.
THEY CAN DO WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO
AND I'M GONNA
PLAY MY STRATEGY.
I DON'T KNOW, WE'LL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
ANYBODY ON THEIR
PERIOD RIGHT NOW?
YES!
LOOKS LIKE SOME PEOPLE
ARE ABOUT TO GET IT.
♪♪♪
HI.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
MISS SPARKLY SHIRT,
COME ON UP HERE
WITH THOSE
PRETTY, BROAD SHOULDERS.
THANKS.
I'M NERVOUS
ABOUT MEETING THE JUDGES.
I THINK I'LL FALL
FLAT ON MY FACE.
I HOPE NOT.
YOU GOT SOME BIG LIPS
LIKE ANGELINA JOLIE.
I KNOW.
EVERYONE IN MY TOWN
CALLS ME THAT.
I THINK THEY'RE REAL.
YEAH, I WAS MADE FUN OF
ALL THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL.
I WANT YOU TO EXPLAIN
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
YOUR BACKGROUND
WITH MODELING.
GOT MY FIRST JOB,
AND I SAVED UP MONEY
UNTIL I COULD AFFORD
TO GO TO A CONVENTION.
HOW MUCH WAS THAT?
NEAR $1,000 OR $1,500--
$1,500 FOR
A MODELING CONVENTION?
A LOT... ANYWAYS.
YOU SHOULD NEVER
HAVE TO PAY SOMEONE
TO TELL YOU WHETHER
OR NOT YOU HAVE
WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE A MODEL.
MOST OF THESE THINGS
ARE SCAMS,
AND THAT'S
WHY YOU'RE STANDING
IN FRONT OF US TODAY
AND STILL TRYING
TO BE A MODEL,
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T WORK.
I THINK WHAT WILL
MAKE ME SHINE OVER
THE OTHER GIRLS IS
I'M HONEST AND I'M REAL
AND I ALSO HAVE
BIG ASS LIPS.
(laughing)
I THINK THAT HELPS.
♪♪♪
I DID THE FUTURE
FARMERS OF AMERICA.
AND WHEN YOU GO THERE,
YOU SHOW LIVESTOCK,
LIKE, SHEEP, UM, PIGS.
HOW DO YOU SELL THEM,
YOU GO TO A FAIR, AND...?
YOU GO TO A FAIR, AND
IT'S AN AUCTION.
OKAY, LET'S GO--LET'S
BE ANIMALS.
(laughing)
JAY IS GONNA BE
A NEW HAMPSHIRE PIG.
PRETEND LIKE THOSE ARE
THE, LIKE, UM, AUCTIONEERS.
KAY, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN,
WELCOME TO
THE COUNTY FAIR.
HERE WE HAVE OUR WONDERFUL
LITTLE SHOW PIG HERE.
COME ON, BABY, SHOW US.
THIS PIG'S GONNA
DO HIS THING.
♪♪♪
(imitating
auctioneer calling)
WHAT IS THIS
PIG DOING?
HI, HI, TYRA.
MY NAME IS LATRICIA,
BUT MY FRIENDS
- CALL ME BEBE.
- BEBE!
I DON'T KNOW WHY
I'M SO LOUD.
IT'S JUST ME.
WELL, BEBE, WHY YOU
WANT TO BE A MODEL?
I WANNA BE LIKE
YOU, TYRA, OKAY?
I WANNA GET MY HAIR DONE,
MY NAILS DONE.
I WANT TO TAKE
MONEY THAT I GET
AND PUT IT TOWARDS
THE U.N.
YOU KNOW, I WANNA
HELP OUT THIRD WORLD
COUNTRY ORPHANAGES.
LIKE, JUST LOOKING PRETTY
AND TAKING PHOTOGRAPHS.
IT'S ABOUT USING
MY TALENT
AND WHAT I LIKE TO DO
TO HELP THE WORLD.
TO SHOW AMERICA
WHAT I HAVE TO OFFER.
IT LOOKS EASY,
BUT I SEE--
IT MIGHT BE--IT LOOKS
KINDA HARD AS WELL.
NOW I'M DETERMINED,
I COULD DO IT.
I'M TIRED OF PEOPLE
BEING MATERIALISTIC.
I'M CONSTANTLY--
OH, IT'S ALL ABOUT BLING-BLING
AND ALL THAT STUFF.
IT'S NOT ABOUT
THE BLING-BLING,
BUT YOU GOT THE
BELT THAT SAYS "KRIS"
AND THE PUMPS THAT
SAYS "PRADA"
AND YOU WANT TO
SAVE THE WORLD, BUT
YOU SAVE THE WORLD
BY HELPING
THE PERSON
RIGHT NEXT TO YOU.
OKAY, LET ME TRY AND
EXPLAIN MYSELF.
WHAT'S THE LAST
COMMUNITY SERVICE
THAT YOU'VE DONE?
(crickets chirping)
FORGET EVERYTHING
I SAID.
- NEW SLATE.
- (sighing)
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS CORYN.
ARE YOU NERVOUS,
CORYN?
YES,
I'M VERY NERVOUS.
I'M NOT USED TO
TELLING PEOPLE
MY FEELINGS
AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
GET READY.
MY LIFE WAS ROUGH
BECAUSE I NEVER KNEW MY DAD.
SO--THEY WERE
NEVER MARRIED.
I KINDA CAME INTO
THE PICTURE.
MY MOM--
SHE WAS ON DRUGS.
SHE HAS NO JOB
RIGHT NOW.
SHE HASN'T CARRIED
A JOB FOR TWO YEARS.
SHE'S TAKING CARE OF
MY LITTLE SISTER.
AND THAT'S WHY
I'M STILL IN THE HOUSE,
'CAUSE I'M WORRIED
ABOUT HER.
DO YOU THINK YOUR SUCCESS
WOULD HELP YOUR MOM
GET OUT OF
HER OWN FUNK?
NO, I DON'T THINK
IT WOULD.
I LOVE YOUR ANSWER,
IT'S VERY REALISTIC,
'CAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THINK THAT, OH,
FAME IS JUST
GONNA CHANGE EVERYTHING.
- I DON'T THINK IT WILL.
- SO THAT'S REALLY GOOD,
THAT YOU'RE CONNECTED
AND YOU UNDERSTAND THAT.
FAME'S NOT MAGIC.
WELL, I'M VERY BAD AT
COMMUNICATING WITH PEOPLE.
I JUST HOLD MY
FEELINGS INSIDE
'CAUSE I'M AFRAID
OF GETTING HURT.
SHE'S DOING THIS
FOR HERSELF
AND SHE'S NOT TRYING
TO SAVE THE WORLD BECAUSE
SHE KNOWS THAT
SHE CAN'T.
(laughing)
♪♪♪
LIKE, LOTS OF PEOPLE
MADE FUN OF ME
BECAUSE OF
MY HAIR COLOR
AND CALLED ME THE
REDHEAD FREAK.
IS THAT YOUR
NATURAL RED HAIR?
YEAH, I'VE NEVER
BEEN ALLOWED
TO DYE MY HAIR.
WHAT COLOR WOULD
YOU WANT TO DYE IT?
BLONDE. I WANTED...
OH, ABOUT
AS NATURAL AS MINE?
WHEN I HIT 18
I STARTED
TO GAIN A LOT
OF WEIGHT WHICH
I'M STILL WORKING ON
TO GET IT OFF.
SHE'S THE WHITE GIRL
VERSION OF MY BOOTY.
THE JIGGLE, THE SIZE,
THE SHAPE--
THAT IS MY BOOTY.
WHAT'S UP, EVERYBODY?
MY NAME'S EBONY,
AND I'M SO EXCITED
TO BE HERE.
I'M JUMPING OUT OF
MY SKIN GOING CRAZY.
I LOVE MY SCHOOL 'CAUSE I'M
STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL.
HEY, WHAT'S UP?
WE'RE GOING IN MY
FAVORITE CLASS RIGHT NOW.
IT'S WHERE I TOOK MY A.P.
U.S. HISTORY CLASS,
A.P. GOVERNMENT,
RIGHT HERE
IT'S MY FAVORITE CLASS.
SO WHY DO YOU
WANT TO BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL?
SOME PEOPLE WANT TO BE
BRAIN SURGEONS.
SOME PEOPLE
WANT TO CURE CANCERS.
I WAS BORN TO BE
A MODEL.
THAT IS MY LIFE.
IT'S DONE.
LIKE, THERE'S NOTHING
ELSE.
PERIOD, POINT BLANK.
TELL US ABOUT
YOUR MOTTO.
WHAT'S YOUR MOTTO?
DON'T GET IT TWISTED.
THAT'S HOW IT IS.
LIKE, IT'S GONNA
COME OUT LIKE THAT.
THAT'S HOW I WANNA
SERVE IT.
DON'T GET IT TWISTED.
I UNDERSTAND HERE
THAT YOU KNOW ALL
THE GIRLS' NAMES.
YEAH, I ALMOST KNOW
EVERYONE'S NAME.
OKAY, I'MMA PUT YOU
TO THAT TEST FOR ONE SECOND.
START.
THERE'S KIM.
SHE'S REALLY COOL, AND
THERE'S SARAH,
AND SHE HAS
KIND OF BIG LIPS.
THERE'S CRYSTAL--
SHE'S CRAZY.
OHH, DIANE.
SHE'S SO COOL.
BRITTNEY FROM HARLEM--
THAT GIRL IS JUST
MMM-MMM-MMM.
THEN THERE'S
NICOLE WHO HAS
DARK BROWN HAIR
AND BLUE EYES.
I LOVE THIS GIRL.
AND THEN THERE'S NIK.
THAT GIRL
IS JUST FIERCE.
SHE'S CRAZY FIERCE.
THERE'S LISA AND--OOH,
SHE IS SO PRETTY.
THERE'S A REDHEAD GIRL--
I'M REALLY IMPRESSED WITH
YOUR MEMORY
BECAUSE I DON'T
REMEMBER ALL THOSE GIRLS.
YEAH, I THINK THAT IS
A HUGE ASSET FOR ME
IN THIS COMPETITION,
BECAUSE I'M ABLE TO GET
MY PERSONALITY OUT THERE.
THAT'S ME.
DON'T GET IT TWISTED,
'CAUSE THAT IS JUST
ME RIGHT THERE.
OKAY, I'M GONNA
BE HONEST.
I'M GONNA BE HONEST.
GIRLS WERE
TALKING ABOUT YOU
AND THEY WERE SAYING
YOU WERE FAKE BECAUSE
YOU'LL TALK ABOUT
ONE PERSON
AND THEN GO TO ANOTHER
PERSON, AND THEN OTHER
- PEOPLE WERE SAYING--
- OKAY, THAT'S A LIE.
IF YOU COULD THINK OF
ANYBODY IN YOUR HEAD--
NOT PHYSICALLY DO IT--
MENTALLY, JUST TO BE OPEN,
LET'S PLAY TRUTH OR DARE.
WHO WOULD YOU PUNCH?
I KNOW I CAN TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW,
AND SHE'S IN THIS ROOM.
I'D PUNCH YOU.
YOU ARE SO OVER
THE TOP.
YOUR ENERGY JUST,
LIKE, GETS ON MY NERVES.
I'M JUST LIKE...
PEOPLE ARE NOW LIKE,
"OH, I DON'T LIKE YOU.
IT'S NOT THAT
I HATE YOU,
I JUST
DON'T LIKE YOU."
AND THAT'S FINE,
DON'T LIKE ME.
MY PERSONALITY IS JUST
TO COME WITH THE REAL.
DON'T GET IT TWISTED.
♪♪♪
TONIGHT YOU GET TO BE
PART OF A HUGE FASHION SHOW.
BUT LIKE MOST
FASHION SHOWS,
THERE'S
ONLY ROOM FOR 20.
♪♪♪
EVERYONE'S BEEN
WAITING FOR THIS MOMENT.
IT'S BEEN BUILDING UP,
YOU KNOW?
"AM I GONNA STAY?
AM I GONNA GO?"
AND THESE
20 MODELS REPRESENT
THE 20 GIRLS WHO
WILL CONTINUE
ON IN THE
RUNNING TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
YOU CAN KINDA
TELL SOME GIRLS
ARE TRYING TO SEE
WHO'S GONNA
MAKE IT AND WHO'S NOT.
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE GETTING
THOSE LITTLE BIT OF LOOKS.
NOW FOR THOSE
16 YOUNG LADIES
WHO DO NOT FIND
THEIR PHOTO AT
A DRESSING STATION
BACKSTAGE,
YOU MUST TAKE A SEAT
IN THE AUDIENCE
AND SUPPORT
THE 20 YOUNG LADIES
WHO ARE CONTINUING ON
IN THE COMPETITION.
WHATEVER HAPPENS
IS GONNA HAPPEN, I GUESS.
I'M JUST HOPING THAT
I'VE PLAYED MY
CARDS RIGHT THIS WHOLE
TIME AND DONE MY JOB.
YOU GIRLS GET TO
RUN THROUGH
THESE BRASS
DOORS BEHIND US
AND TAKE A LOOK
FOR YOUR PHOTOS.
THROUGH THESE
GOLDEN DOORS,
YOU WILL
FIND YOUR FATE.
SO ON THREE...
EN FRANCAIS, N'EST PAS?
UN... DEUX... TROIS!
(squealing)
♪♪♪
OUR POLAROID WAS
ON THE SIDE WHERE
THE CLOTHES WAS
AND IF IT WAS,
THAT MEANS
THAT YOU WERE
ONE STEP CLOSER TO
BEING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
(squealing)
I'M ACTUALLY IN A DAZE
RIGHT NOW.
I FOUND MY CARD.
I DON'T KNOW,
IT'S JUST LIKE,
SUCH AN INTENSE MOMENT.
(squealing)
I FEEL RELIEVED.
I JUST FEEL LIKE,
I'M JUST TOUCHING MY STAR,
AND I'M ALMOST BECOMING IT
AND I'M ALMOST--
I'M ALMOST THERE.
(squealing)
FOUND MY PICTURE.
I WAS STROKING
THAT PICTURE.
I WAS LIKE,
"DAMN, I LOOK
PRETTY GOOD
IN THAT PICTURE."
YOU MADE IT, GIRL, I TOLD
YOU YOU MADE IT!
I TOLD YOU!
♪♪♪
LIKE, I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
A FAILURE.
EVERYTHING THAT
I'VE TRIED TO DO,
THAT I REALLY WANTED
TO DO,
I'VE NEVER BEEN ABLE
TO, LIKE, COMPLETE IT.
I WANT TO GO HOME.
I'M VERY STRONG.
I DON'T LIKE PEOPLE TO
SEE ME CRY, BUT WHEN
YOU WANT SOMETHING
SO BAD AND
YOU KNOW THAT IT IS
THIS CLOSE TO HAPPENING,
IT JUST HURT ME AND I
JUST STARTED CRYING.
JUST HURT SO BAD.
WHAT, BITCH?
YOU GUYS,
YOU HAVE FOUR MINUTES.
LET'S DO IT.
OKAY, FIND YOUR--
DON'T TAKE ANY TAGS OFF.
I'M GONNA GO OUT THERE
AND WORK IT.
AND THIS WILL DETERMINE
WHO'S GONNA BE IN THE HOUSE.
♪♪♪
WE'RE ALL PRETTY MUCH
WINNERS AT THIS POINT,
BUT I'M GONNA END
UP WITH THE CONTRACT,
SO I NEED TO GO AHEAD
AND STEP MY "A" GAME UP NOW.
ONE MINUTE LEFT,
YOU GUYS!
I'M SCARED THE
MOST OF FALLING PRETTY MUCH
JUST BECAUSE I HAVE A
HABIT OF TRIPPING
EVERYWHERE AND HEELS
ARE NOT MY FORTE QUITE YET.
♪♪♪
AND IT'S TIME,
YOU GUYS.
♪♪♪
(cheering)
NOW THAT'S AMAZING.
♪♪♪
I TRY MY BEST
AND, LIKE,
THE BEST I
CAN DO IS A TRIP.
SO IT PROBABLY DOES PUT
ME AT A DISADVANTAGE.
♪♪♪
- WORK THAT, WORK THAT...
- ALL RIGHT NOW.
MY WALK
IS A DISASTER.
I REALLY NEED TO
WORK ON THAT.
HERE, I'LL
PUT IT BACK THERE.
WHERE'S YOUR THING?
♪♪♪
SHE SHOULD HAVE
SUCKED THAT IN.
♪♪♪
(applause)
(squealing)
ALL RIGHT, LADIES.
WORK IT OUT!
GOOD JOB, GOOD JOB.
BUT YOU GUYS REALIZE
THERE IS
STILL ANOTHER ELIMINATION.
EVERYBODY HAS A SPECIAL
SOMETHING ABOUT THEM.
IT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT TO
EVEN THINK WHO
MIGHT BE LEAVING.
I JUST HOPE IT
AIN'T ME
BECAUSE MAYBE I SHOULD
START PACKING RIGHT NOW.
GOOD LUCK TO ALL
OF YOU LADIES.
YOU REALLY DID
A GOOD JOB TONIGHT.
BUT TYRA HAS ONE MORE
THING FOR YOU.
THIS IS JUST
THE BEGINNING
OF A COMPETITION,
AND UNTIL I
GET INTO THAT HOUSE,
THIS IS NOT OVER.
♪♪♪
(cheers and applause)
HOW'S EVERYBODY DOING?
(applauding)
GOOD!
ARE YOU SURPRISED
YOU'VE MADE IT THIS FAR?
YES.
MMM!
(laughter)
SO WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A ONE-ON-ONE,
ME AND EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF YOU, ONE ON ONE.
I'M PRETTY NERVOUS
TO MEET WITH TYRA.
LIKE, I'M
FROM A SMALL TOWN
SO I DON'T MEET
STARS EVER.
ALL RIGHT,
SO PRETTY GOT YOU HERE,
BUT PRETTY'S NOT GONNA GET
YOU TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
IT'S ALL
ABOUT PERSONALITY
AND WHAT'S BEAUTIFUL
ON THE INSIDE.
SO RIGHT NOW I WANT
YOU TO START THINKING
ABOUT THE VERY LAST
THING THAT YOU
CAN TELL ME
TO CONVINCE ME
WHY YOU NEED TO BE ONE
OF THE FINALISTS
TO BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN
MORE EXCITED AND
MORE TERRIFIED
AT THE SAME TIME.
IF I DON'T PUT
ON THE BEST
IMPRESSION
FOR HER RIGHT NOW,
THAT, MAYBE IT--THIS IS ALL
GONNA GO AWAY FOR ME.
ALL RIGHT,
SO, BE THINKING.
ALL RIGHT.
- BYE!
- BYE.
♪♪♪
HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY.
HI, TYRA.
SO, REGINA,
THIS IS YOUR CHANCE
- TO GIVE YOUR FINAL PLEA.
- YEAH, I NEED--
I NEED YOU TO KNOW
HOW READY I AM, TYRA.
LIKE, IT'S TIME
FOR ME TO MODEL.
AND THAT'S LIKE--I FEEL
THE MOST ALIVE WHEN
I'M ON A RUNWAY.
WHAT HAPPENS IF THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN FOR YOU?
IT'S GONNA HAPPEN
FOR ME.
I KNOW IT.
AND I KNOW
I CAN DO IT,
BUT I JUST WANT TO PROVE
TO EVERYONE ELSE.
WHO DO YOU
WANT TO PROVE IT TO?
TO EVERYONE.
TO YOU.
NOW IT'S MY TURN
TO PROVE MY LIFE.
I'M GONNA PROVE IT.
SINCE I DIDN'T
GET A CHANCE
FOR MY MOM TO DO IT
FOR ME, I'M DOING IT.
SO WHO DO YOU
THINK OUT THERE
HAS QUIRKY KIND
OF LOOKS?
LIKE, REGINA.
WHEN WE WERE
DOING THE POSE-OFF,
THEY SAID, "DO A PROFILE,"
AND SHE WENT--
AND TO ME IT
LOOKED LIKE
SHE WAS VOMITING.
WHAT IS THE LAST THING
THAT YOU WANT TO TELL ME
BEFORE I
RE-MAKE THIS DECISION?
I DON'T GET AS
MUCH ENJOYMENT
OUT OF
DAIRY QUEEN, OBVIOUSLY,
AS I WOULD OUT
OF MODELING.
I WANT
MY OWN BILLBOARD.
I WILL BE ON A
BILLBOARD.
SO WHAT DO
YOU WANNA TELL ME?
- WHAT'S THE LAST THING--
- WELL, FIRST I WANNA ASK--
CAN I ASK YOU SOMETHING?
UH-HUH.
OKAY, I JUST WANTED TO
ASK YOU WHAT IT
WAS LIKE TO
WORK WITH WILL SMITH.
(record needle scratches)
YOU COULD ASK ME
ANY QUESTION
IN THE WORLD
ABOUT MODELING,
AND YOU WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT WILL SMITH?
I HAVE THIS DREAM
OF DRIVING AWAY IN MY CAR
FROM MY TOWN ONE
MORNING
AND JUST NEVER
LOOKING BACK.
BUT I'LL PROBABLY
NEVER DO THAT.
WHEN I WOULD DIE,
YOU KNOW,
JUST TO
SHOW YOU THAT MY HEART
REALLY WANTS THIS
AND I'M READY
TO MAKE THIS MY LIFE
IF YOU GIVE ME
THE OPPORTUNITY.
WHAT IS THAT?
OH, I WROTE DOWN
ALL THE QUESTIONS
I WANNA ASK YOU.
LET ME SEE THAT.
WELL, I HAD TO
SCRUNCH IT UP.
THERE'S
THIS MATURITY LEVEL.
THERE'S SO MUCH DEEP
INSIDE ME.
MY PARENTS HAVE
PREPARED ME ACADEMICALLY
FOR VARIOUS FIELDS,
BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT I WANT TO DO,
THIS IS WHAT I WANT TO DO.
I DID FUTURE
FARMERS OF AMERICA,
AND THROUGH THAT,
I HAD TO, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, RAISE
ALL THESE ANIMALS
AND REALLY SELL THEM,
AND SO I THINK,
YOU KNOW, I COULD
REALLY SELL COVERGIRL.
'CAUSE YOU
SOLD COWS AND STEERS.
YEAH, IT'S NOT EXACTLY
THE SAME THING.
IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT YOU WANT TO TELL ME
ABOUT YOU THAT I DON'T
KNOW ALREADY?
BECAUSE I'M SO
BOOTYLICIOUS AND CURVACEOUS.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
I'M AN ARTIST.
WHEN I WALK DOWN A RUNWAY--
JUST TO--TO MAKE ART.
I AM VERY
SMART AND I'M MATURE,
GOT A GOOD HEAD ON
MY SHOULDER.
- AND I GOTTA--
- HEAD ON YOUR SHOULDER?
- YEAH.
- OR SHOULDERS?
SHOULDERS, BOTH,
BOTH.
I'M 18.
I'M STILL
IN HIGH SCHOOL,
AND I HAVE A FEVER
FOR MODELING.
I AM ON FIRE FOR IT,
AND I'M NOT A LIVING ROOM,
DINING ROOM FIRE.
I'M A FOREST FIRE,
TYRA.
AND RIGHT NOW I'M
STANDING IN FRONT OF
THE WOMAN WHO INSPIRED
ME TO DO THIS.
BANANAS.
AND I WANT THIS
SO BAD.
I'M GONNA FIGHT
FOR THAT CONTRACT,
TOOTH AND NAIL
TO BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHT, YOU GUYS,
WE REALLY
GOTTEN TO
KNOW THESE GIRLS.
WE SPENT OUR PANEL
TIME WITH THEM.
I ACTUALLY DID SOME
ONE-ON-ONES WITH THEM.
NOW IT'S TIME TO TAKE
IT TO THE FINALS.
KIM.
SHE LOOKED LIKE
A BROKEN DOWN CABOOSE
ON THE RUNWAY.
I FELT LIKE SHE WAS
TRYING TO BE FEMININE
FOR US ON THE RUNWAY
INSTEAD OF BEING HERSELF.
SO WAS SHE LIKE A
MAN IN A DRESS?
I DON'T THINK A MAN IN A
DRESS WOULD LOOK THAT BAD.
LOOK AT HER TOP LIP.
IT'S, LIKE,
DRAWN LIKE A LITTLE
CARTOON CHARACTER.
(imitating drawing)
HERE'S ASHLEY.
I DON'T SEE THE
PRETTY GENE.
YOU KNOW WHAT, IT'S THE
FLAIR ON THE EARRING
TOOK AWAY
THE PRETTY GENE.
BUT THIS GIRL--
I THINK SHE'S REALLY,
REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
SHE'S ALMOST MAYBE
ACTRESSY, THOUGH.
IS THAT LISA?
SHE BLEW ME AWAY
ON THE RUNWAY LAST NIGHT.
SHE KNEW WHERE THE
PRESS BIN WAS.
SHE KNEW HOW TO POSE
AT THE END OF THE RUNWAY.
BUT IF THIS IS HOW
SHE PHOTOGRAPHS,
I'M SCARED TO SEE HER
IN A PHOTO SITUATION.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT
BRE'S EYES ARE
VERY FAR APART.
YOU KNOW, THAT MAKES
FOR A REALLY GOOD MODEL.
(New York accent)
SHE'S VERY ROUGH,
THOUGH.
SHE TALKS LIKE THIS.
HAVE YOU HEARD
HER TALK?
SHE'S, LIKE,
IN YOUR FACE.
(normal voice)
WHAT ABOUT JAYLA?
I LIKE HER.
SHE HAD A LITTLE
RICKETS.
SOMETHING IN HER JOINTS
WERE JUST NOT RIGHT.
OKAY, NIK.
THE GREAT THING
ABOUT THIS GIRL
IS THAT THE
CAMERA LOVES HER.
SARAH, SARAH.
WHEN SHE WALKED
DOWN THE RUNWAY,
SHE WAS SO BROAD,
AND SHE HAD
HER FEET LIKE THIS,
THAT LITERALLY ONE
FOOT WAS ON
EITHER SIDE
OF THE RUNWAY.
I LOVE THE
FULL LIPS.
YOU GOT 'EM, BABY,
AND I GOT 'EM, TOO.
EBONY.
DON'T GET IT...
TWISTED.
I MEAN, SHE'S
GOT GORGEOUS SKIN.
I DO LOVE HER EYES.
ALL RIGHT, NOW WE
GONNA LOOK AT KYLE.
I LIKE KYLE.
MISS DAIRY QUEEN.
SHE'S JUST HAPPY.
I FEEL LIKE KYLE
IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF A COMMERCIAL MODEL.
CASSANDRA.
MISS BEAUTY QUEEN
FROM TEXAS.
I THINK THIS
GIRL IS SO BEAUTIFUL,
AND SHE CAN SELL ME
FACE CREAM ANY TIME.
DON'T YOU THINK
SHE'S A LITTLE...
- A LITTLE PINCHED?
- LITTLE PINCHED.
APRIL.
I'M ON THE FENCE WITH
THIS ONE, I DON'T KNOW.
I REALLY DO THINK
SHE CAN
DO SOMETHING
INTERESTING.
CORYN.
I THINK CORYN NEEDS
THAT EYEBROW TWEEZING KIT,
DON'T YOU THINK?
OKAY, NICOLE.
THIS IS THE GIRL WHO
GOT ON HER KNEES IN PANEL.
I THINK SHE'S VERY
FASHION.
I LOVE HER LOOK.
REGINA.
I LOVE HER FACE.
I FEEL LIKE
HER BODY TYPE
ISN'T PLUS SIZE
AND IT ISN'T MODEL SIZE.
I THINK THAT
SHE SHOULD
GAIN WEIGHT AND
BECOME A PLUS SIZE MODEL.
SHE WOULD BE SO
STUNNING.
DIANE.
HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT A PLUS SIZE MODEL
BEING IN THIS COMPETITION
BY HERSELF?
I LOVE THIS GIRL.
SHE CAN GO ON
AND TAKE THAT TITLE.
I THINK SHE'S A GREAT
UP-CLOSE GIRL.
AT A DISTANCE
SHE DOESN'T CARRY.
ALL RIGHT, WE'VE MADE
OUR DECISION, GUYS.
♪♪♪
I COULD JUST THROW UP,
I'M SO NERVOUS.
AND I'M JUST TRYING
TO KEEP MY COMPOSURE,
BUT I COULD JUST
THROW UP.
TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF GIRLS
TRIED OUT FOR THIS
COMPETITION,
AND THEN I NARROWED
IT DOWN TO 36 GIRLS.
I'M SCARED,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I'M
CONFIDENT BECAUSE, LIKE,
I'M THE GEM.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY ANYONE WOULDN'T WANT TO
BUTTER THEIR BREAD
WITH ME.
THEN I NARROWED
IT DOWN AGAIN TO THE
20 BEAUTIFUL WOMEN THAT
STAND BEFORE ME.
13 OF YOU WILL
CONTINUE ON THE JOURNEY
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND SEVEN OF YOU
WILL HAVE TO GO BACK HOME.
I WANT TO MAKE IT
INTO THAT HOUSE,
SO, IF I'M ELIMINATED,
IT'S GONNA
BE A CRUSHING BLOW.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GONNA CALL...
♪♪♪
CASSANDRA FROM TEXAS.
(cheering)
ARE YOU MAKING
FUN OF ME?
YES.
(laughter)
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
NIK.
OH!
♪♪♪
KYLE.
ME?
(squealing)
(laughing)
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL--
ASHLEY.
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
(laughing)
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M
GOING TO CALL...
BRE.
(laughter)
(crying)
♪♪♪
KIM.
(laughter)
♪♪♪
I HAVE SEVEN NAMES LEFT,
AND THE NEXT GIRL
THAT I'M
GONNA CALL...
SARAH.
(laughter)
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M
GOING TO CALL...
JAYLA.
OH!
WALK OVER THERE.
♪♪♪
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M
GOING TO CALL
HAS A LOT RIDING
ON THIS COMPETITION.
♪♪♪
CORYN.
OH, MY GOD.
(laughter)
TELL ME WHAT
YOU'RE FEELING RIGHT NOW.
I DID IT.
♪♪♪
ONLY FOUR MORE
SPOTS LEFT.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
NICOLE.
(laughter)
YOU OKAY?
(muffled whimper)
BREATHE.
(inhales, exhales)
THIS IS SO SURREAL.
(laughter)
♪♪♪
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
♪♪♪
BOBO ON 36th STREET,
DIANE!
(laughter)
I'M GONNA
STAY HERE FOR BOBO.
(laughter)
I ONLY HAVE TWO
NAMES LEFT.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
♪♪♪
LISA.
OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD!
I ONLY HAVE ONE
NAME LEFT,
AND THAT
13th GIRL WILL ROUND
OUT THESE 12
OVER HERE.
AND SHE'LL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE LAST NAME...
IS SOMEONE
THAT WHEN I WOKE UP
THIS MORNING, I DIDN'T
REALLY THINK THAT SHE
SHOULD BE A FINALIST.
I JUST WASN'T CONVINCED,
BUT WITH THE
ONE-ON-ONE SESSION
THAT I HAD WITH HER,
IT CHANGED MY MIND.
♪♪♪
DON'T GET IT TWISTED,
MISS EBONY.
(screaming)
(laughing)
♪♪♪
DON'T GET IT TWISTED.
(laughter)
(crying)
YES,
YOU'RE IN, BABY.
I'M NOT SOMEBODY TO
WEAR MY HEART
ON MY SLEEVE, AND
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE
I'VE BEEN SHARING
MY EMOTIONS,
AND I'M NOT
DOING IT ANYMORE.
IT'S NOT WORTH IT,
I TRIED IT.
YOU GUYS GOT
THIS FAR.
SO IT MEANS THAT YOU
HAVE AMAZING POTENTIAL.
LET ME SEE THIS.
OH, SEE, SHE CRIED OFF
SOME OF THAT EYE LINER,
AND LOOK HOW LOVELY
SHE LOOKS.
♪♪♪
WHY CAN'T I BREATHE?
SERIOUSLY, I'M HAVING,
LIKE, ANXIETY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE
THIS JUST HAPPENED.
THIS IS LIKE AN ABSOLUTE
DREAM COME TRUE.
♪♪♪
SHE CALLED MY NAME.
I DIDN'T THINK
SHE WAS GONNA CALL ME.
I COULDA JUST
THREW UP.
I WAS JUST
STANDING THERE LIKE,
"YOU KNOW, I'M JUST
GONNA THROW UP
RIGHT HERE,
AND THAT'S IT.
I'MMA TAKE MY SHOES
OFF AND THROW UP."
(squealing)
YOU DID IT.
YOU GUYS ARE WELCOME,
Y'ALL.
♪♪♪
DON'T GO AWAY.
THE SECOND HALF OF OUR
TWO-HOUR PREMIERE
IS NEXT.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED FIRST?
THE 13 GIRLS GET
ACQUAINTED
WITH THEIR NEW DIGS...
OH, MY GOD!
(screaming)
OH, MY GOD.
AND EACH OTHER...
WE ALMOST FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE A ROBOT.
YOU KNOW HOW SOCIOPATHS
DON'T FEEL EMOTION
AND THAT'S WHY THEY CAN
KILL PEOPLE WITHOUT EVER
FEELING BAD ABOUT IT?
ONLY I NEVER KILLED
ANYBODY.
(record needle scratches)
THIS IS SO BIZARRE.
♪♪♪
I'M GOING NUTS, 'CAUSE WE'RE
IN BEVERLY HILLS.
IT'S LIKE WOW,
YOU'VE MADE IT THIS FAR.
AND WE'RE ALL JUST
STANDING AROUND,
EXCITED AND ANXIOUS,
AND ALL OF THE SUDDEN
THE TWO J's WALK UP.
♪♪♪
HELLO.
(cheering)
OF COURSE, I'M THINKING
IT'S A CHALLENGE.
YOU GIRLS ARE IT,
THE 13 THAT ARE HERE.
- BRILLIANT, BRILLIANT.
- YOU GIRLS ARE STANDING
HERE IN BEVERLY HILLS,
CALIFORNIA.
(cheering)
THIS IS WHERE
ALL THE STARS ARE.
THIS IS WHERE THE
STARS ARE MADE.
AND TO BE A
TOP MODEL,
YOU NEED TO LOOK LIKE
A STAR, BE A LIKE A STAR.
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO MAKE
SOME OF YOU LIKE STARS,
BUT ONLY ONE OF YOU CAN
BE THE REAL STAR
OF "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL."
SO TODAY, YOU GIRLS
ARE GOING
TO GO ON A TOUR OF
ALL THE STARS' HOMES.
WOW.
AND THERE IS ONLY
ONE PERSON
THAT COULD TAKE
YOU ON THE TOUR
OF ALL THE
STARS' HOMES.
GIVE IT UP.
HERE HE IS,
MR. ROBIN LEACH!
(cheers and applause)
LADIES, COME ON DOWN.
THE ADVENTURE OF A LIFETIME
IS ABOUT TO BEGIN.
ALL I'M THINKING IS,
YOU KNOW,
CHAMPAGNE
AND CAVIAR DREAMS.
I MEAN, IT'S ROBIN LEACH,
FOR CRYING OUT LOUD.
I WAS LIKE,
"HE'S STILL ALIVE?"
I THOUGHT THAT WE SHOULD
START OUR TOUR
WITH A LITTLE
CHAMPAGNE,
- AWW.
- BUT FOR YOU,
WE GIVE YOU
APPLE CIDER.
THAT WORKS.
SWEET.
NO, NO, NO, FROM
GLASSES, YOUNG LADY.
♪♪♪
ROBIN HANDS A BOTTLE
TO LISA AND SHE
JUST DRINKS IT OUT
OF THE BOTTLE, AND I AM
THINKING, "OH, MY GOSH,
HAVE SOME CLASS."
BUT I DON'T WANT
TO SAY ANYTHING TO HER
'CAUSE I DON'T LIKE TO
START A CONFLICT.
AND EVEN
THOUGH I MAY HAVE
BEEN RAISED MORE PRIVILEGED
THAN SOME PEOPLE,
THERE'S NO REASON TO
RUB THAT IN PEOPLE'S FACES.
TO AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
CHEERS.
- CHEERS!
- WOO!
♪♪♪
SO THIS IS RODEO DRIVE.
SO YOU HAVE EVERY DESIGNER
IN THE WORLD OF FASHION
HAS A BOUTIQUE
ON THIS STREET.
♪♪♪
I'M FROM BOONVILLE,
MISSOURI,
AND I'M HERE
IN LOS ANGELES,
AND IT'S JUST INCREDIBLE.
IT'S LIKE A MOVIE TO ME.
THIS IS THE MOST EXPENSIVE
REAL ESTATE IN THE WORLD.
THEY GO UP AS HIGH
AS $25 MILLION.
IT'S THE HOME TO ALL
THE TOP PEOPLE
IN THE
FASHION INDUSTRY.
CHRISTIE BRINKLEY,
CINDY CRAWFORD,
HEIDI KLUM,
CLAUDIA SCHIFFER
AND ELLE MacPHERSON.
AND WHEN YOU'RE
A TOP MODEL,
THIS IS
WHERE YOU'LL LIVE.
♪♪♪
SO WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
FABULOUS PLACES TODAY,
BUT WE'VE SAVED
THE BEST FOR LAST.
ARE YOU ALL READY?
- YEAH.
- LET'S GO.
♪♪♪
SO SURE ENOUGH,
WE PULL UP TO THIS HOME.
MY FIRST IMPRESSION IS THAT
IT'S TYRA'S HOUSE.
THIS IS A VERY
SPECIAL HOUSE.
IT CONTAINS A VERY
UNIQUE CAST OF CHARACTERS.
IN FACT,
IT IS THE HOME
OF AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL!
SOMEBODY TAKE THE KEY!
GO ON IN!
GOOD LUCK.
(screaming)
OH, MY GOD!
(squealing)
IS THAT EVA?
EVA, SHE WON!
(screaming)
♪♪♪
GOTTA FIND A ROOM!
OUT OF MY WAY!
THIS HOUSE IS SO CRAZY.
♪♪♪
AND IT'S JUST COOL
THAT IT'S A DEPARTMENT STORE
BECAUSE I LOVE SHOPPING.
ACTUALLY, YOU LOOK CUTE.
- OBVIOUSLY, YOU LOOK CUTE.
- NO, I DON'T, WHATEVER.
THERE'S A SECTION FOR
BELTS AND SCARVES.
A SECTION FOR
SHOES AND SHADES.
THE ROOMS, THEY'RE LIKE,
THEY ALL HAVE
A DIFFERENT THEME.
LIKE OURS IS "BLING
IT ON."
(screaming)
DO WE GET TO KEEP
THESE THINGS?
I DON'T KNOW, BUT
I KNOW THAT I LIKE 'EM.
CORYN AND NICOLE,
THEY RUN INTO THE BEDROOM
THAT I LIKE,
THE STILETTO ROOM.
AND OUR ROOM IS PERFECT,
WHICH WAS AWESOME.
THIS IS NICOLE.
NICOLE, THIS IS
US RIGHT HERE.
(screaming)
- YEAH!
- (screaming)
THEN, DOWN BELOW US
IS, LIKE, PERFUME ROOM.
THERE'S PERFUME
EVERYWHERE.
THEY REALLY
SMELL GOOD.
WHO KNEW
I WAS GONNA ACTUALLY
HAVE TO SLEEP IN
A BOUTIQUE?
I WENT FROM WORKING IN
ONE TO SLEEPING IN ONE.
- TAKE A MINUTE.
- GIRL! GIRL!
- TAKE A MINUTE, BRE.
- GIRL!
TAKE A MINUTE.
♪♪♪
WELCOME TO OUR ROOM.
- OH, MY GOD!
- TOTALLY OUR ROOM.
I LOVE ASHLEY.
I HAVE A GOOD
TIME WITH HER.
WE'RE FRIENDS.
YEAH, NO, WE'RE GREAT.
SINCE THE VERY
BEGINNING.
THIS ROOM WAS
MADE FOR US, ACTUALLY.
OUR HOUSE IS AWESOME.
I DON'T THINK I WILL EVER
LIVE IN ANOTHER HOME
IN MY LIFE THAT
WILL HAVE A HOT TUB
RIGHT OUTSIDE MY
BEDROOM DOOR.
I REALLY DON'T.
(laughing)
OH, LOOK!
THAT'S FROM OUR
FIRST PHOTO SHOOT!
YA-YA, OH MY GOSH!
ARE YOU FULL-ON
LESBIAN?
I MEAN,
YOU'RE NOT BI OR...
I ONLY DATE GIRLS,
YEAH.
A LOT OF THESE GIRLS,
LIKE, DON'T KNOW ANYONE,
LIKE, WHO IS GAY.
AND, LIKE, IT'S, LIKE,
KIND OF EXCITING FOR THEM.
I MEAN, I MISS MY
GIRLFRIEND FROM HOME,
AND, LIKE, I'M IN, LIKE,
AN OPEN RELATIONSHIP,
BUT I DON'T PLAN
ON ACTING ON THAT.
WE'RE OPEN RIGHT NOW.
THOUGH IT'S PROBABLY
RIDICULOUS,
HOPEFULLY
IT'S RIDICULOUS,
'CAUSE I'M NOT GONNA
HIT ON ANYONE HERE.
THAT'S CRAZY.
I'LL MAKE OUT
WITH YOU, KIM, OKAY?
(laughing)
OKAY, LIKE, WHATEVER.
JUST BEING FROM A
SMALL TOWN,
I DON'T KNOW ANY
FULL-BLOWN LESBIANS,
BUT I'M OPEN ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
(laughing)
♪♪♪
I KNOW THAT ALL OF US
ARE GOING TO PROBABLY
GET ON EACH OTHER'S
NERVES AT SOME POINT,
AND IT'S GONNA GET
A LITTLE CRAZY,
BUT, UM, I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO TOMORROW,
WHATEVER IT MAY BRING,
AND... GOOD NIGHT!
(crickets chirping)
♪♪♪
I REALLY
DON'T REMEMBER
THE LAST TIME I
HAD BREAKFAST.
CEREAL IS GOOD, TOO.
I LIKE CEREAL,
AND I REMEMBER--
OH, LOOK AT MY FEET.
I KNOW.
- THIS FLOOR IS--
- THE HOUSE IS DIRTY.
CASSANDRA IS
A CONTROL FREAK.
SHE'S JUST OVERBEARING AND
DRIVING PEOPLE NUTS.
IT'S JUST, THERE'S NOT
VERY MUCH ROOM IN THIS ROOM.
IT'S COLD.
IT'S NOT THAT BAD.
OHHH!
IT'S VERY COLD.
I REALLY DID NOT
LIKE HER.
SHE DROVE ME NUTS.
I'LL NEVER FORGET
WATCHING HER CRY HER
EYES OUT 'CAUSE THEY
CUT HER HAIR OFF.
DON'T CRY IF THEY
CUT YOUR HAIR OFF.
REMEMBER,
IT ALL GROWS BACK.
UH, YEAH, IN A
FEW YEARS.
TO ME,
CASSANDRA SEEMS THAT
SHE FEELS THAT SHE'S BETTER
THAN EVERYONE ELSE.
I'M NOT FEELING
THIS WHOLE AWAKE THING.
CASSANDRA--I THINK THAT
SHE NEEDS A RUDE
AWAKENING
IN HER LIFE
'CAUSE SHE'S SPOILED.
SO I THINK THAT'S GONNA
BE HER WEAKNESS.
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL!
WHOO!
OKAY, OKAY.
IT SAYS, "DO YOU HAVE
HIGH SELF-ESTEEM?
HOW MUCH
ARE YOU WORTH?
BE READY AT 4 P.M."
(screaming)
♪♪♪
HI, HOW ARE
YOU DOING?
I'M GONNA BE YOUR
DRIVER FOR TONIGHT.
HEY, LADIES, WE GOT
A DRIVER.
COME ON.
♪♪♪
WE WALK OUTSIDE TO A
STRETCH WHITE LIMOUSINE.
(screaming)
WE OPEN THE DOOR...
AND EVERYTHING INSIDE OF
IT IS TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
IT'S DECKED OUT IN
PINK AND MAKEUP EVERYWHERE.
SO I THINK THAT
IS REALLY COOL
THAT THIS IS
THE CAR THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE RIDING IN
THROUGHOUT
THIS WHOLE COMPETITION.
IT'S REALLY AMAZING.
MUSIC?
(hip-hop music playing)
OH, MY GOD, OKAY.
♪♪♪
ALL OF US
ARE JUST THINKING,
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WHERE ARE WE GOING?
WE PULL UP TO
A BUILDING,
AND I CAN SEE THAT
IT IS A NIGHT CLUB.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHT, TONIGHT,
WE'RE AT THIS HUGE EVENT.
IT'S A FASHION EVENT,
VERY BLING IN L.A.
SO TONIGHT, WE'RE THROWING
YOU GUYS RIGHT INTO WORK.
AND I MEAN WORK.
THERE IS A RED CARPET
OUTSIDE
BECAUSE
"LIFE & STYLE" MAGAZINE
IS THROWING YOU A BIG
PARTY HERE TONIGHT.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A FASHIONISTA CROWD,
PRESS, CELEBRITIES,
YOU GUYS!
(cheering)
AND YOU GIRLS ARE GOING
TO BE WALKING IN THIS SHOW.
AND THIS IS YOUR
FIRST CHANCE
IN THIS
COMPETITION TO SHOW
EVERYONE WHAT
YOU'VE GOT.
♪♪♪
MY HEART, LIKE, JUMPS
AND SINKS AT THE SAME TIME
BECAUSE I KNOW
I CAN'T WALK.
I'M HAPPY AND, LIKE, REALLY
SCARED AT THE SAME TIME.
♪♪♪
WE ARE GOING TO BE DOING
A FASHION SHOW
AT THE
"LIFE & STYLE" PARTY.
(shouting)
THE FACT THAT I'M GONNA
BE DOING A SHOW
IN FRONT OF
CELEBRITIES, THAT'S CRAZY.
THE PEOPLE ARE STARTING
TO COME IN
RIGHT NOW
AT THE RED CARPET.
SO WHILE WE PREPPED THESE
DRESSES FOR THE SHOW,
IT'S UP TO YOU GIRLS
TO GET YOUR MAKEUP READY.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA START
GETTING YOU GUYS
DRESSED AND
INTO YOUR FIRST LOOKS.
- READY?
- READY.
DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
♪♪♪
I DON'T WEAR MAKEUP,
SO I DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT TO DO.
WHEN YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING,
YOU BETTER STICK TO
WHAT YOU KNOW.
PUT ON A
LITTLE MASCARA,
LITTLE GLOSS AND
POOF UP THE HAIR.
WHAT?
I'VE NEVER PUT ON MAKEUP
BEFORE EVER.
DUDE.
KIM IS FREAKING
OUT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE SHE DOES NOT
WEAR MAKEUP.
I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO.
THIS IS--I WANNA WRITE
WITH THIS.
HEY, WHO
WANTS TO HELP ME
WITH MY EYE LINER?
'CAUSE I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO PUT IT ON.
♪♪♪
OBVIOUSLY, WE HAVE
TO DO OUR OWN MAKEUP,
AND KIM GOES TO ASHLEY,
SHE'S LIKE, "I NEED HELP
WITH MY MAKEUP,"
AND ASHLEY WAS LIKE,
"WELL, YOU BETTER
FIGURE IT OUT."
AND KIM WAS LIKE,
"AREN'T WE ROOMMATES?
LIKE, AREN'T YOU SUPPOSED
TO HELP ME?"
I WAS LIKE,
"THAT IS SO RUDE."
HERE, I'LL HELP YOU.
I LITERALLY HAVE
NO IDEA HOW TO DO THIS.
OKAY.
I KNOW THAT
THERE WERE GIRLS
WHO WERE HELPING
PEOPLE OUT,
BUT I WASN'T
HELPING ANYBODY.
THAT WASN'T MY
CONCERN
BECAUSE THIS
IS A COMPETITION.
YEAH, I DEFINITELY
WONDER WHY,
SINCE WE'RE SUCH
GOOD FRIENDS,
SHE CAN'T
HELP ME OUT.
ALSO, YOU KNOW,
IT MAKES ME REALIZE THAT
AS MUCH AS I
LIKE ASHLEY,
SHE'S NOT SOMEONE THAT
I CAN TRUST.
♪♪♪
THE RUNWAY.
IT IS THE MOST
HECTIC PUZZLE EVER.
♪♪♪
I THINK THEY'D GIVE US
THIS CRAZY RUNWAY--
THE SQUARE SHAPE--
FOR A REASON.
AND SO THERE'S GONNA
BE TWO DIFFERENT PEOPLE
GOING ON THE STAGE
AT ONE TIME.
SOME OF US
WILL HAVE TO GO ONE WAY
AND THE OTHER GIRLS HAVE
TO GO ANOTHER WAY.
BUT EVENTUALLY WE CROSS.
AND WE'RE PROBABLY GONNA
SLIDE AND FALL ON OUR FACE.
THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE BACKSTAGE,
AND WE'RE JUST LOOKING
FOR A PLACE
WHERE WE CAN PRACTICE
OUR WALK IN THESE SHOES.
I THINK I HAVE THE
WORST WALK.
♪♪♪
YOU A
LITTLE SHAKY THERE,
- AREN'T YOU?
- I DON'T LIKE TO WALK,
AND MY FEET
WEREN'T SWEATING.
ACTUALLY, I DON'T REALLY
THINK I HAVE A BAD WALK,
I THINK I JUST HAVE
BAD BALANCE.
WELCOME TO THE REAL,
GLAMOROUS LIFE OF MODELS.
I'M GONNA INTRODUCE
YOU GIRLS
REALLY QUICKLY
TO NATE DOGG,
WHO IS GONNA BE AN M.C.
HERE TONIGHT.
(cheering)
GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN.
HEY, WHAT'S UP, MAN,
HOW ARE YOU?
SO, THESE ARE
OUR GIRLS.
THEY LOOK
GREAT, DON'T THEY?
WHAT'S UP, LADIES?
NATE DOGG IS A
HIP-HOP ICON.
HE'S GREAT.
HE'S GONNA BE
GIVING YOU THE VIBE
FOR YOUR WALK.
AND IT IS SO IMPORTANT TO
KINDA TAKE ON WHAT HE SAYS
AND THEN PUT YOUR
TOP MODEL SPIN ON IT.
- ALL RIGHT?
- THAT THEY ARE.
SO YOU'RE GONNA SEE
THEM OUT THERE,
AND WE'RE GETTING
READY TO START THE SHOW?
- LET'S DO IT.
- ALL RIGHT.
(screaming)
♪♪♪
OKAY, ASHLEY, GO.
THE GRACE
OF A SENSUAL WOMAN.
♪♪♪
'CAUSE I WAS THE FIRST
ONE OUT.
THAT WAS A REALLY
GOOD BOOST OF ENERGY.
QUIRKY GIRLS ARE
COLORFUL.
OH, NO, I WAS
FIERCE ON THAT RUNWAY.
I WAS FIERCE.
THE POSH LADY.
I FEEL GREAT ON
THE RUNWAY.
I'M WALKING DOWN
AND I'M THINKING,
THIS IS A LOT OF FUN.
THIS IS NO PROBLEM.
I CAN DO THIS.
♪♪♪
WHAT'S MAKING
THIS CHALLENGE HARD
IS THE GIRLS WERE
MESSING UP,
GOING THE WRONG WAY.
SO THERE'S DEFINITELY
GONNA BE SOME COLLISIONS,
I'M FEELING.
LET'S HOPE
I'M NOT ONE OF THEM.
HOW DOES A SPUNKY
GIRL WALK?
♪♪♪
CUTTING-EDGE TRENDSETTER
CAN RULE ANY GOWN.
I LIKE THE RUNWAY.
I HAVEN'T EVER SEEN
MYSELF WALK A RUNWAY
AND I'M PROBABLY
GONNA LAUGH WHEN I DO.
BUT I LOVE HAVING PEOPLE,
LIKE, WATCH ME.
♪♪♪
WHEN IT'S MY TURN,
I LOOK LIKE A CHICKEN
WITH MY HEAD CUT
OFF, I THINK.
DANGEROUS.
SO I WALK OUT THERE
AND, LIKE, I KNEW
I WAS GONNA FALL.
IT'S NOT A FULL-OUT FALL,
THANK GOD.
BUT IT WAS
HUMILIATING.
AND SHE'S STILL FINE.
MMM, MMM, MMM.
ASHLEY, YOU'RE UP.
♪♪♪
ALL THE STRESS
BACKSTAGE
AT THE RUNWAY
SHOW, IT'S CRAZY.
HURRY, GIRLS.
WORK IT OUT.
COME ON,
I NEED SOMEBODY NOW.
I LOVE THE CHAOS.
I'M, LIKE, "I'M
IN THE MIDDLE OF CHAOS,
THIS IS COOL."
SARAH, COME ON,
GET OUT THERE.
SARAH HAS
THE WORST WALK.
SHE NEEDS SOME WALKING
LESSONS
REAL QUICK HERE.
THIS ONE IS STILL
QUITE QUEENLY.
AND THEN I DID
THE SAME THING AGAIN.
OHH!
THE TRIPPING DOESN'T
REALLY MAKE ME FEEL GREAT.
I JUST HUMILIATED
MYSELF TWICE.
♪♪♪
HEY, I WANT
TO THANK YOU GUYS
FOR COMING OUT AND HAVE
A GREAT NIGHT.
THAT'S IT, RIGHT?
THAT'S IT, THAT'S IT.
I THINK IT CAME OUT
GOOD, BUT I THINK PEOPLE
PROBABLY NOTICED THAT WE
WERE AMATEUR MODELS.
ALL RIGHT, SO I'M
GONNA SEE YOU GUYS LATER.
I HONESTLY HAVE TO SAY
THAT WAS THE ABSOLUTELY
WORST FASHION
SHOW I'VE EVER DONE
'CAUSE HALF OF YOU WENT
THE WRONG WAY.
GOOD TRY, THOUGH.
(cheering)
I'M GONNA
SEE YOU GUYS SOON.
(cheering)
♪♪♪
OH, MY GOD.
BRITTNEY'S NAKED!
(squealing)
WHEN WE GOT INTO THE LIMO,
A LOT OF GIRLS GOT LOOSE.
WE LEFT FROM THE PARTY,
THEY STILL WANTED
TO TAKE
THE PARTY WITH US.
HEY, WHAT'S UP,
BEAUTIFUL GIRL?
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?
KIM, YOU THINK I'M
BEAUTIFUL?
YEAH.
(squealing)
ALL OF THE SUDDEN
JUST SARAH IS
JUMPING OVER THE SEAT
AND STARTS MAKING OUT
WITH KIM.
YEAH!
I DIDN'T REALLY THINK THAT
THAT WAS GONNA HAPPEN.
(laughing)
OH, MY GOD.
HER TONGUE'S
STICKING OUT.
AND SHE'S GOT SOME CRAZY
CANTALOUPE LIPS.
QUIET, QUIET, QUIET.
ONE DOWN, 11 TO GO.
♪♪♪
YEAH, THIS IS BROADENING
MY HORIZONS.
LIKE, KIM
IS LIKE THIS GREAT--
LIKE, DUDE, SHE'S, LIKE,
A LESBIAN.
SHE'S GOT
ALL THESE DYNAMICS.
EVERYONE IS LIKE
EIGHT LAYERS DEEP.
THERE IS ONLY ONE PERSON
THAT I JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHO?
CASSANDRA.
YOU CAN TELL THAT GIRL
AIN'T STRUGGLED AT ALL.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT
I MEAN?
IT'S LIKE SHE'S
ALMOST LIKE A MACHINE.
DOES SHE RECHARGE
HER BATTERY?
WHERE DOES
SHE PLUG IN?
IT'S LIKE, "I'M BREAKING
DOWN RIGHT NOW."
(laughing)
CASSANDRA
IS A WEIRDO.
SHE JUST THINKS SHE'S ALL
MISS PRIMPER AND PROPER
'CAUSE SHE'S
PAGEANT QUEEN.
GIRL, I WAS JUST
TALKING ABOUT YOU.
WHAT DID I DO?
YOU DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING, DUDE.
WE'RE WAITING
FOR YOU--
LIKE WE ALMOST FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE A ROBOT.
YOU'RE JUST THE PAGEANT
GIRL AND IT'S--
LIKE,
WHAT'S THE DEAL?
YOU KNOW HOW SOCIOPATHS
DON'T FEEL EMOTION
AND THAT'S WHY
THEY CAN KILL PEOPLE
WITHOUT EVER, LIKE,
FEELING BAD
ABOUT IT?
ONLY I NEVER
KILLED ANYBODY.
(crickets chirping)
THIS IS SO BIZARRE.
I'M LIKE,
WHAT IS UNDERNEATH
THOSE EYEBALLS?
WHAT IS SHE THINKING?
IT'S NOT THAT I DON'T
FEEL COMFORTABLE
SHARING THINGS
WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
IT'S JUST THAT I'M
NOT AN EMOTIONAL PERSON.
TYRA MAIL!
SO HERE IT IS, GUYS.
"IT'S A BIRD,
IT'S A PLANE.
NO, IT'S A TOP
MODEL IN THE MAKING.
BE READY AT 5:30 A.M."
(squealing)
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING,
HOW ARE YOU?
I KNOW IT'S EARLY.
SO TODAY,
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
YOU GIRLS FLYING
AS SUPERHEROES.
YEAH!
SO TO CAPTURE
THIS SHOT,
I'VE GOT AN
AMAZING PHOTOGRAPHER.
HE SHOT OUR VERY OWN
TYRA BANKS MANY TIMES.
HIS NAME IS
MIKE RUIZ.
I NEED YOU
GUYS TO BE FIERCE.
I NEED YOU TO
BRING IT.
I NEED TO SEE
SUPERHERO TOP MODEL.
(cheering)
I'M GONNA TAKE
YOU BACK TO HAIR
AND MAKEUP, ALL RIGHT?
♪♪♪
DO YOU WANT ME TO HOLD
ANYTHING FOR YOU?
NOPE, I'M ALL GOOD.
BUT THANKS FOR
SUCKING UP.
(laughs)
OH, GOOD,
IT'S A GOLD HARNESS.
♪♪♪
I HAVE THIS
GREAT OUTFIT ON.
I REALLY THINK IT'S THE BEST
ONE THEY'RE GONNA MAKE.
I MEAN, LET'S BE
HONEST.
MY GOD.
THIS IS GONNA BE SO
PAINFUL, I CAN TELL.
WORRY ABOUT THE POSES
RIGHT NOW.
I'M READY.
YOU GOTTA
SQUEEZE YOUR BUTT.
I'VE NEVER FLOWN AND I'VE
NEVER DONE A PHOTO SHOOT.
SO IT'LL BE
KIND OF EXCITING.
READY?
YOU TELL HIM.
I'M READY WHEN
YOU ARE.
YEAH, WORK IT OUT,
WORK IT OUT, WORK IT OUT.
CHIN UP.
CAN YOU SPLIT
THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN
VERTICAL AND LEANING
ALL THE WAY
FORWARD?
UP, UP, UP, UP
A LITTLE.
UP A LITTLE, YEAH.
'CAUSE SHE'S
TIPPING DOWN A LOT.
IMAGINE YOU'RE
SWOOPING IN ON AN ENEMY,
- KIND OF LIKE... WHOOSH.
- OKAY.
♪♪♪
SHE DOESN'T GET
THE ANGLED ONES.
SHE'S NOT GETTING IT.
YOU GOTTA FEEL IT.
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T FEEL
IT, THEN I DON'T FEEL IT.
OKAY, OKAY.
♪♪♪
KIM DID NOT
IMPRESS ME TODAY.
KIM JUST SEEMS LIKE
THE TYPE OF PERSON
WHO WOULD BE
ABLE TO ROCK ANYTHING.
AND TODAY, KIMBERLY FELL
A LITTLE FLAT.
I SUCKED.
DUDE, YOU WERE SUCKING
REAL BAD.
- IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
- I KNOW.
ASHLEY WAS LIKE, "YOU SUCK,"
FOR THE WHOLE TIME.
AND IT'S
JUST KINDA LIKE,
"YOU KNOW, THAT'S REALLY
UNHELPFUL."
I GUESS I JUST--NEVER
DONE THIS BEFORE.
NO, I FEEL YOU.
YEAH.
♪♪♪
YOU HAVE NO NECK
AT ALL.
LET'S TRY THAT AGAIN.
I KNOW YOU
CAN DO THIS, ASHLEY.
JUST DON'T SHRINK
THAT NECK AWAY.
YOU MIGHT BE ABLE
TO HOLD THAT POSE.
THAT'S GREAT.
NECK, NECK,
NECK, NECK, NECK,
NECK.
STILL LOSING YOUR NECK.
♪♪♪
I HOPE I DID OKAY.
I DON'T HAVE A GOOD
FEELING ABOUT IT.
I MEAN,
I TRIED MY HARDEST.
IT ALMOST SEEMS
LIKE IT'S
SUPPOSED
TO BE AN EXCUSE.
IT'S NOT,
IT'S JUST, YOU KNOW,
A MATTER OF PHYSICS.
I CAN ONLY STRETCH
MY BODY SO MUCH.
ASHLEY DEFINITELY
STRUGGLED A LITTLE BIT
ON THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
IF WE'RE LUCKY, WE GOT ONE
SHOT OF ASHLEY.
♪♪♪
IF YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GIVE ME 100%,
IT'S GONNA JUST LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE GIVING ME 5%.
- ALL RIGHT.
- ALL RIGHT?
WORK IT,
WORK IT, WORK IT,
WORK IT.
SELL IT TO ME.
BETTER, MUCH BETTER.
GOOD JOB.
I'M REALLY CURIOUS WHAT
YOU WERE THINKING
WHEN YOU WERE
IN THAT POSE.
'CAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE, "HI,
I'M DESCENDING DOWN
TO TAKE A DUMP ON
THE SUPERHERO THRONE."
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU'RE OUT.
♪♪♪
BOY, DOES MY
BUTT HURT.
LIKE, THINK OF BATMAN.
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES, WHEN
HE'S GOTTA GRAB SOMEONE.
WHOOSH--AND THEN
HE GRABS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
IT'S KIND OF WEIRD TO BE
A SUPERHERO.
I'VE NOT SEEN
A SUPERHERO SHOW.
I WATCH BARBIES.
I WATCH GIRLIE STUFF.
THAT'S NOT
PRETTY AT ALL.
WELL, IT'S A SUPERHERO.
WELL, YOU BETTER TRY
TO BE SUPERHERO.
NO BALLERINA.
♪♪♪
THERE YOU GO.
NIK PRETENDED NOT
TO KNOW
ANYTHING
ABOUT SUPERHEROES,
BUT NIK TOTALLY
TURNED IT OUT.
I'M LIKE A
CRAZY RAINBOW BRIDE.
HEAD'S A LITTLE HIGH.
I CAN'T SEE YOU.
LET'S TRY IT AGAIN.
GREAT, GREAT,
GREAT, GREAT.
THAT WAS WAY BETTER,
KYLE.
IF IT'S REALLY
UNCOMFORTABLE RIGHT AWAY,
YOU GOTTA TELL ME, I'LL
BRING YOU BACK DOWN.
♪♪♪
WHEN I SAW THE CABLES
IN THE AIR,
I WAS TERRIFIED.
YOU LOOK WORRIED.
I HATE HEIGHTS.
THAT'S, LIKE, THE
ONLY THING I SAID
THAT I'M AFRAID OF,
IS HEIGHTS.
I'M VERY BAD AT
HEIGHTS, BUT,
I KNOW THERE'S SOME
OBSTACLES I'M GONNA HAVE
TO OVERCOME, AND THIS
IS JUST ONE OF THEM.
♪♪♪
GO, DIANE!
THAT LOOKS
LIKE NEFERTITI.
GIVE ME SUPERHERO.
DO IT.
GO, GO, GO.
DO YOUR THING.
THAT WAS GREAT,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
DON'T JUST POSE IN THE AIR
FOR ME, ALL RIGHT?
I WANT YOU
TO LOOK FIERCE.
YOUR FACE LOOKS
PRETTY, DIANE.
GOOD JOB, SHE'S DONE.
♪♪♪
I'M SO EXCITED.
I'M READY TO DO THIS.
I WANT ALL TEN FRAMES
EXCELLENT OUT OF YOU.
I DON'T THINK THERE
IS ANY
GIRLS THAT WILL
DO BETTER THAN ME.
YOU LOOK LIKE MY "MATRIX"
FANTASY RIGHT NOW.
GORGEOUS!
I'M BASICALLY
HOLDING POSITIONS
THAT ARE JUST
LIKE, SICK.
THE BODY IS JUST
ON POINT, ALL RIGHT?
I'M AWESOME
AS A SUPERHERO.
THAT LOOKS GOOD.
♪♪♪
I'M SCARED TO DEATH.
FEEL A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE?
OH, MY GOSH.
YOU'LL BE ALL RIGHT.
YOU'RE NOT
GOING ANYWHERE.
OH, MY GOODNESS, IT'S
A LONG WAYS DOWN.
♪♪♪
KEEP ONE LEG STRAIGHT.
DON'T KICK IT OUT.
AS I'M UP HERE
I HAVE TO STAY FOCUSED
AND DO THE BEST
THAT I CAN.
YES, YES, YES,
POINT THE TOE!
I'M REALLY IMPRESSED
WITH CORYN'S
COURAGE UP ON THE WIRE.
♪♪♪
GOOD JOB, CORYN.
YOU CAN BRING HER
DOWN.
THIS IS
TOTALLY ME, DUDE.
THIS LOOKS LIKE ONE OF MY
HALLOWEEN COSTUMES.
I LOOK EVIL.
I LOOK LIKE I'M
ABOUT TO KILL HER.
♪♪♪
I WOULD RATHER BE A
SUPERHERO THAN A VILLAIN,
BUT SINCE I AM A GOOD GUY
IN REAL LIFE,
THEN I CAN KINDA
SHOW MY DARK SIDE.
♪♪♪
REALLY GOOD.
YES, YES, YES,
POINT THE TOE!
OH, YOU LOOK FIERCE.
CASSANDRA DID
A REALLY GOOD JOB.
YOU KNOW, SHE'S A
PAGEANT GIRL
AND I EXPECTED SOMETHING
A LITTLE SAFE FROM HER.
BUT SHE KIND OF
STEPPED OUT OF HER BOX
AND TURNED IT OUT.
NICOLE, I WANT TO
LOOK LIKE YOU'RE FLYING.
POINT YOUR FEET.
THAT'S A GREAT SHOT.
INTENSITY.
THAT'S GOOD.
OH, SHE'S BORN READY.
LOOK AT HER.
SHE'S FEELING IT.
WORK IT OUT,
WORK IT OUT.
WORK!
GIVE IT TO ME AT THE
END, LIKE, YEAHHH!
HARDER, HARDER, HARDER,
HARDER, HARDER.
SHE'S GOOD.
♪♪♪
FLYING, FIGHTING SOMEBODY,
SAVING SOMEBODY.
I WANT YOU TO GET
LIKE A PICTURE IN YOUR MIND
BECAUSE IF YOU BELIEVE IT,
I'LL BELIEVE IT.
OKAY.
BUILD YOUR INTENSITY.
BUILD
YOUR INTENSITY.
IF YOU PUT YOUR
HEAD BACK
TOO FAR,
IT'S NOT PRETTY.
I DON'T KNOW,
I WAS JUST SCARED OF,
LIKE, LOOKING A FOOL
LIKE I USUALLY DO, SO
I PROBABLY DID.
BUT YOU KNOW,
I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE ENOUGH TROUBLE
POSING ON THE GROUND.
SARAH.
THAT LAST SHOT WAS REALLY
PRETTY, YEAH.
SARAH'S A
LITTLE AWKWARD.
AND UP ON A WIRE,
IT ONLY MADE
THE SITUATION EVEN WORSE.
SARAH REALLY JUST
LUCKED INTO GETTING
ONE GOOD SHOT, AND
THAT'S IT.
I'M HAVING FUN.
JAYLA, I WANT YOU TO
REALLY PICTURE SOMEONE
YOU'RE GOING TO ATTACK,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
♪♪♪
INTENSITY!
BEAUTIFUL.
YOU HAVE TO FEEL
THE INTENSITY
THROUGH
YOUR WHOLE BODY.
I LIKE THAT, IT LOOKS
LIKE YOU'RE FLYING.
YOU ROCK.
SHE'S LIKE THE BIG
BAD BITCH, I LOVE IT.
♪♪♪
I REALLY
EXPECTED MORE OF YOU
TO KIND OF FAIL
AT THIS.
I'M MUCH MORE IMPRESSED
THAN I WAS LAST NIGHT.
- YEAH.
- AT OUR FASHION SHOW?
THAN THE FASHION SHOW.
(cheering)
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL!
ALL RIGHT, Y'ALL,
TYRA MAIL.
OH, MY GOD.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL
MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 12 WILL CONTINUE ON
WITH THE HOPE
OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE
ELIMINATED."
TYRA.
- ELIMINATION.
- WE KNEW IT WAS COMING.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO
TELL WHO MIGHT GO HOME.
BUT I KNOW THAT
SARAH--SHE FELL.
IF I GET
ELIMINATED FIRST,
UM, IT WOULD REALLY
SUCK.
I DON'T
WANT TO GO HOME.
I'M SCARED OF BEING
ELIMINATED.
I THINK THAT
I COULD HAVE DONE
BETTER TODAY,
AND I HOPE
THAT I HAVE AT LEAST
A FEW GOOD PICTURES.
♪♪♪
HEY, LADIES.
HI.
WELCOME TO YOUR
FIRST TIME
EVER IN
THIS JUDGING ROOM.
THANK YOU.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S GONNA BE
ONE PERSON'S LAST TIME.
NOW, WE HAVE
SOME AMAZING PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A
CONTRACT WITH
MODELING
COMPANY FORD MODELS.
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
WHICH WILL BE SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A COVER OF
"ELLE GIRL" MAGAZINE,
THE MAGAZINE FOR
THE GIRL THAT
DARES TO BE DIFFERENT.
AND THE LAST
BUT VERY SPECIAL PRIZE
IS A CONTRACT WITH
COVER GIRL COSMETICS
WORTH $100,000.
NOW, WE HAVE SOME
AMAZING JUDGES HERE
AT "AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL."
THE FIRST IS...
(British accent)
THE NOTED FASHION
PHOTOGRAPHER,
NIGEL BARKER.
HELLO, LADIES.
HI.
OUR NEXT JUDGE IS
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
DIVA WALKING TEACHER
EXTRAORDINAIRE.
HI.
J., DO YOU WANNA EXPLAIN
YOUR CORSAGE?
EACH OF THESE FLOWERS
REPRESENT ONE OF YOU GIRLS,
AND IN EACH WEEK THERE
WILL BE ONE
THAT JUST FALLS OFF
LIKE A WILTING FLOWER.
SAD BUT TRUE.
OUR LAST JUDGE IS SOMEONE
THAT IS A FASHION ICON.
SHE IS ONE OF THE
TOP THREE MOST PROFOUND,
MOST INFLUENTIAL FASHION
MODELS ON THIS EARTH.
LADIES, I BRING YOU
TWIGGY!
("Spring" from Vivaldi's
"Four Seasons" playing)
HI.
GREETINGS FROM ENGLAND.
(laughs)
TWIGGY WAS
THE FIRST TEENAGER
TO ACTUALLY BECOME
A SUPERMODEL
IN THE '60s.
TWIGGY'S BEEN
ON THE COVER OF
NEARLY EVERY
FASHION MAGAZINE.
NOT A LOT OF SUPERMODELS
HAVE DONE THAT.
ACTUALLY, MY
MAMA LOVED TWIGGY,
AND TWIGGY ACTUALLY
POPULARIZED
THIS EYELASH
THING WHERE, LIKE,
YOU DRAW, LIKE,
FAKE EYELASHES
ON THE BOTTOM, AND
THOSE WERE NAMED TWIGGIES.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR YOUR
INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND YOU GUYS ARE GONNA
BE EVALUATED
ON THE "LIFE & STYLE"
PARTY THAT YOU GUYS DID.
YOU'RE ALSO GONNA BE
JUDGED ON
YOUR
SUPERHERO PHOTO SHOOT.
ALL RIGHTY,
LISA'S FIRST.
LISA, SO YOU HAD
TO WORK IT
AT A FASHION SHOW AT
THE "LIFE & STYLE" EVENT.
YES.
AND WE HAVE YOU
RIGHT HERE.
♪♪♪
LISA, YOU
HAD A REALLY NICE,
STRONG, CONFIDENT LOOK
AND CONSISTENT.
YOU HAD, I THINK,
THE PERFECT ATTITUDE
FOR THIS KIND
OF SHOW.
COOL, MAN.
YOU LOOKED LIKE YOU
WERE HAVING FUN AS WELL.
YEAH--I LOVE RUNWAY.
A FEW THINGS THAT I'LL
PROBABLY GET TO YOU ABOUT
LATER ON ABOUT THAT WALK IF
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH ME, AND
I'LL CLEAN THAT UP, OKAY?
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, MISS J.
SO YOU WERE POSING
AS A SUPERMODEL SUPERHERO,
AND HERE IS YOUR
BEST SHOT.
WHOA.
GREAT SHOT.
WOW.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
BEAUTIFUL.
YOU OWN THIS PICTURE.
IT'S GREAT.
ALL RIGHTY, NICOLE,
SO YOU HAD TO
WALK THE RUNWAY,
AND HERE YOU ARE.
♪♪♪
WHOA, I TAKE MY HAT
OFF TO YOU
'CAUSE I COULDN'T
WALK IN THOSE HIGH HEELS.
SO, WELL DONE.
- THANK YOU.
- SHE GOT TO COME SEE ME.
(laughing)
AND HERE'S
YOUR BEST SHOT.
YEAH, YOU LOOK VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE,
LIKE,
"I'M IN A HARNESS
- AND IT HURTS."
- DARN IT.
YOU LOOK QUITE WIDE
IN THIS PICTURE,
AND YOU'RE A
VERY SLIM GIRL.
HOPEFULLY,
YOU WILL TAKE ALL
THE INFORMATION THAT
WE GIVE YOU
AND JUICE IT LIKE
A FLORIDA ORANGE.
LISTEN TO EVERYTHING
WE'RE SAYING.
TAKE IT ALL IN.
WELL, YOU'LL LEARN.
THANK YOU.
SO, KYLE, YOU HAD
TO WORK IT
AT THE
"LIFE & STYLE" EVENT
ON THE RUNWAY, AND
HERE YOU ARE.
♪♪♪
IT'S REALLY FUNNY.
YOUR NATURAL WALK
IS MUCH MORE
INTENSE FOR ME
THAN YOUR RUNWAY WALK.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A
REALLY SEXY WALK.
THAT WAS
A GREAT WALK.
- DIDN'T YOU THINK IT WAS--
- OF COURSE, TWIGGY.
SHE ALMOST SHOWED A
A BIT OF KNICKERS.
(laughing)
WELL, AT LEAST
SHE HAD KNICKERS ON.
OH, RIGHT, EXACTLY.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
THAT POSE IS AMAZING,
ISN'T IT?
OOH, SCARY FACE, KYLE.
BECAUSE SUPERHEROES ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE LIKE,
"I'M COMING
TO SAVE THE WORLD."
AND INTIMIDATING.
YEAH, AND YOU'RE LIKE,
"HI. DO YOU NEED HELP?"
(laughing)
NEXT WE HAVE BRE.
♪♪♪
YOU'VE DEFINITELY GOT
THAT HORSE TROT GOING,
WHICH ACTUALLY FOR
ME WORKED.
FOR ME, A
VERY PECULIAR WALK.
AND HERE'S YOUR
BEST SHOT.
WOW, WHAT
A GREAT POSE.
THAT LOOKS LIKE
UNDERWATER ALMOST.
BUT IN A SHOT LIKE THAT,
EYE CONTACT
WOULD HAVE BEEN
SO MUCH MORE POWERFUL.
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES WHEN
YOU'RE TAKING PICTURES,
YOU'VE GOTTA BRING IT HOME
WITH THE FACE.
CONNECT WITH THAT EYE.
NEXT WE HAVE KIM.
OH, NO.
OOH, WHAT WAS
THE NECK?
I DON'T KNOW.
♪♪♪
YOU'RE TRYING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE NOT.
YOU'RE TRYING TO BE SO SEXY
AND SO GIRLY,
AND YOU LOOK LIKE
A MAN IN A DRESS, GIRL.
YOU JUST NEED TO
GO WITH
YOUR STRONG
MASCULINITY.
THAT'S WHAT
BROUGHT YOU HERE.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
♪♪♪
THIS WHOLE PICTURE,
UNFORTUNATELY,
DOESN'T REALLY WORK.
YOU DON'T LIKE THE BODY?
I DON'T LIKE ANYTHING
IN THIS PICTURE, REALLY.
REALLY?
I LIKE THE BODY.
YOU ACTUALLY--I HAD A FLASH
OF ME 40 YEARS AGO.
- RIGHT?
- ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU.
NEXT IS EBONY.
♪♪♪
YOU LIKE
THAT BACK SHOT, HUH?
LIKE, "I'MMA SHOW YOU
THE BACK OF THE DRESS."
YEAH, I LOVE IT.
THAT'S MY FAVORITE.
AND HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
♪♪♪
IT'S JUST NOT GOOD.
YOU LOOK LIKE...
- E.T.
- YEAH.
THOSE ARE MY INITIALS.
YOU'RE CHANNELING.
E.T., PHONE HOME.
NEXT IS DIANE.
YOUR FACE IS
SO UNDENIABLY BEAUTIFUL
ON THAT RUNWAY,
BUT I WAS STUCK
AT THE FACE,
BECAUSE THE
WALK WAS LIKE WAHH.
AND HERE IS YOUR
BEST SHOT.
THIS ONE
KINDA REMINDS ME
OF YOUR RUNWAY WALK
WHERE IT WAS
LIKE FIERCE
FACE AND THEN JUST
KINDA FORGOT ABOUT
THE REST OF IT.
KNOW YOUR BODY,
LEARN YOUR BODY,
LOVE YOUR BODY.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT
WE HAVE ASHLEY.
YOU'RE ALL HAPPY.
I'M ALWAYS HAPPY.
ALL RIGHT, ASHLEY,
HERE ARE YOU AT
THE "LIFE
& STYLE" EVENT.
♪♪♪
WHAT DID YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT WALK?
I--TOO SLOW.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE
PRETTY BORING.
I THINK
THAT LOOKS GREAT.
YOU DON'T
WANT EVERYONE TO BE
THE SAME ON THE
RUNWAY.
AND HERE'S
YOUR BEST SHOT.
LESS SUPERHERO, MORE
SQUASHED VILLAIN.
YOU LOOK IN PAIN
OR LOOK
LIKE YOU'RE DYING
OR SOMETHING.
DO YOU KNOW HOW
SUPERHEROES SOMETIMES,
LIKE, THEY GET A LITTLE
TASTE OF KRYPTONITE
AND THEY
GET A LITTLE WEAK?
SHE'S DEFINITELY
GOT THE KRYPTONITE.
AND WAITING FOR THE
PARAMEDICS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT
WE HAVE NIK.
♪♪♪
WHAT'S UP, NIK?
HOW YOU DOING?
HERE IS YOUR
BEST SHOT.
WOW.
IT'S GREAT.
I LOVE THE LEGS.
THEY'RE BRILLIANT.
IT JUST LOOKS LIKE
A GREAT SHOT ALL AROUND.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT
IS CORYN.
♪♪♪
I LOVE THAT THEY PUT
YOU IN LONG DRESSES
BECAUSE
I LOVE YOUR BODY.
BUT THE THING IS,
YOU DIDN'T CARRY THEM
THE WAY YOU
SHOULD HAVE.
AND HERE
IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU'VE GOT A VERY
MUSCULAR BODY.
IT'S DEFINITELY--
IT'S VERY SORT OF
SPORTS KIND OF
MODELING,
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO BE
ABLE TO WEAR DRESSES.
JAYLA.
♪♪♪
OH!
ARE YOU ITCHING?
ARE YOU SCRATCHING?
(laughing)
EVEN THOUGH
IT WAS A LITTLE
KINDA ALL OVER THE PLACE,
YOUR ENERGY.
I THINK YOU JUST HAVE
TO KNOW HOW TO
HONE YOUR ENERGY.
AND HERE'S YOUR
BEST SHOT.
WOW.
OOH, GREAT FACE.
I LOVE THAT.
I THINK
IT'S HALFWAY THERE.
THE BODY'S GREAT,
AND I THINK
THE FACE
JUST KIND OF LOST IT.
CASSANDRA.
AND HERE YOU ARE
ON THE RUNWAY.
VERY PROM WALK.
YOU LOOK
LIKE THAT SORT OF
GORGEOUS GIRL AT
SCHOOL,
BUT IT JUST DIDN'T
TRANSLATE AS A MODEL TO ME.
I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT HER I LIKED.
I WAS CONCENTRATING MORE
ON KEEPING THE DRESS UP
AND NOT FLASHING
THE AUDIENCE.
YOU KNOW,
I THOUGHT THERE WASN'T
ENOUGH FLASHING
IN THAT SHOW.
YEAH, IT WAS...
DOWN, BOYS, DOWN,
BOYS.
THE THING...
(laughter)
OH, I'M SORRY.
SORRY.
(laughter)
THERE'S ONLY ONE BOY
AT THIS TABLE.
ALL RIGHT,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
WOW.
MMM, I LIKE THAT.
NOT WHAT I EXPECTED
OUT OF YOU.
ME EITHER.
I THOUGHT YOU
WERE GONNA BE LIKE...
♪ AHH ♪
♪ WHO SING LIKE
THE BEAUTY QUEEN. ♪
I LOVED THE SHOOT.
I HAD HARDLY ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE HARNESS,
AND I REALLY FELT
LIKE I WAS A SUPERHERO,
SO IT WAS VERY EASY FOR ME
TO JUST KINDA...
I SEE.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS SARAH.
HI.
HI, SARAH.
HERE YOU ARE.
♪♪♪
SARAH, I THINK
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE
A BETTER RECOVERY.
YOU ACTUALLY LOOKED
LIKE YOU
WERE UPSET AND
WANTED TO RUN OFF
AS FAST AS POSSIBLE.
AND HERE
IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
I LIKE THAT.
IT'S KIND OF SEXY
AND SCARY
AT THE SAME TIME.
PERSONALLY, I LIKE THIS
PICTURE AS A CLOSEUP.
WHEN I GO
WIDE ON THIS PICTURE,
YOUR LEGS LOOK EXTREMELY
SHORT.
♪♪♪
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR
THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND THEN WHEN
ICALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH
ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪
CASSANDRA.
SOMETHING MISSING
WITH CASSANDRA.
I ALMOST LIKE--
I DON'T SEE HER
WHEN SHE'S STANDING
IN FRONT OF ME.
YOU THINK IT'S
THE PAGEANT BACKGROUND?
BECAUSE SHE WAS LIKE,
"IT DIDN'T HURT.
THE HARNESS WAS GREAT.
EVERYTHING WAS PERFECT.
I LOVED IT.
VOTE FOR ME."
(laughing)
- EBONY.
- WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS PHOTOGRAPH
OF EBONY
IS THE WORST PICTURES
OUT OF THE BUNCH.
I DON'T REALLY
SEE HER AS A MODEL,
BUT SHE IS BEAUTIFUL.
CORYN.
GREAT BODY.
HANDS DOWN FOR
THE BODY.
I ACTUALLY
DON'T LIKE HER
MUSCLE TONE BEING
THAT STRONG.
I THINK IT DOES GET A
LITTLE BIT TOO ATHLETIC.
SARAH.
POOR SARAH, SHE WAS
THE ONE WHO STUMBLED
ON THE CATWALK.
LIKE WHEN SHE STUMBLED
IN THE SHOW,
YOU COULD
SEE IT IN HER FACE.
AND IT JUST BROKE
ALL OF HER
CONFIDENCE
STRAIGHT THROUGH.
DID YOU SEE HER,
SHE'S LIKE...
SHE BROKE DOWN.
SARAH'S GOT AN
AMAZING FACE.
WE'VE GOTTA SEE
THAT FACE
MORE IN
PICTURES AGAIN.
NIK.
NIK IS, AT THE MOMENT,
I THINK SORT OF
THE SILENT WEAPON THAT
THE GIRLS HAVE
TO LOOK OUT FOR.
ASHLEY.
I LIKE THIS
PICTURE OF ASHLEY.
IT FEELS LIKE SHE IS
A FALLEN SUPERHERO.
ASHLEY HAS A PRETTY GENE,
AND SHE THINKS
THAT PRETTY
IS ALL SHE NEEDS.
WE HAVE WHAT WE
CALL A
"PRETTY GENE"
IN MY FAMILY.
OH, WE ALL
HAVE THAT, TOO.
LIKE, "YES, I'M
PRETTY.
YES,
I'M DOING WELL."
SHE JUST DOESN'T HAVE THAT
MAGIC INGREDIENT FOR ME.
AND THAT'S
WHAT'S MISSING.
SHE HAS NO OOMPH.
LISA, I ABSOLUTELY
ADORE LISA'S FACE.
SHE PHOTOGRAPHS REALLY
GREAT.
WELL, I THINK
LISA IS A SORT
OF DIAMOND IN
THE ROUGH.
DIANE.
I THINK DIANE
IN THIS PICTURE--
THE BODY DOESN'T WORK,
BUT THE FACE HAS IT.
KIM.
YOU LOOK AT HER,
SHE HAS A COMPLETE
UNIQUENESS ABOUT HER.
SHE'S ANDROGYNOUS.
SHE'S VERY
ANDROGYNOUS.
THE FACE DOESN'T DO IT
FOR ME IN THAT SHOT.
KYLE.
SHE LOOKS LIKE
A VERY PRETTY GIRL,
BUT NOTHING WHAMS OUT AT ME
AND KNOCKS ME SIDEWAYS.
JAYLA.
I DO LIKE HER
LIGHT SPIRIT.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT
SHE'S A LITTLE BUBBLY.
I'M NOT SURE
SHE WAS
THAT GREAT
ON THE RUNWAY.
THAT'S THE ONE NEGATIVE
THING
I HAVE TO SAY
ABOUT JAYLA,
WAS THAT SHE'S
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
NICOLE.
I THINK NICOLE IS
VERY YOUNG,
AND I THINK HER LOOK IS
THE ENGLISH ROSE LOOK.
MODELS NEED
TO BE CHAMELEONS.
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
TRANSFORM.
HAVING ONE LOOK
IS REALLY LIMITING.
- YEAH.
- BRE.
I ACTUALLY DIDN'T
LIKE BRE'S WALK.
SHE LOOKED LIKE A
HORSE THAT HAD GONE WRONG.
WELL, IF ANYBODY KNOWS
THE SMELL OF
THAT CHEESE BRIE--
THAT FRENCH CHEESE--
GIRL, YOU KNOW.
(laughing)
OOH, YOU ARE AWFUL.
- BUT I LIKE YOU.
- NO.
(laughter)
♪♪♪
13 BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME.
BUT I ONLY HAVE 12
PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE 12 PHOTOS
REPRESENT
THE 12 GIRLS
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS
BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
♪♪♪
NIK.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN
THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
LISA.
CASSANDRA.
DIANE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU.
- WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING
TO CALL--JAYLA.
KYLE.
BRE.
♪♪♪
EBONY.
THANK YOU.
CORYN.
THOSE EYEBROWS ARE
KILLING ME.
GROUCHO MARX GIRL.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
NICOLE.
♪♪♪
DID YOUR HEART STOP?
CONGRATULATIONS.
♪♪♪
I ONLY HAVE TWO PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
♪♪♪
KIM.
WHAT?
CONGRATULATIONS, KIM.
YOU'RE STILL IN
THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
WILL ASHLEY
AND SARAH PLEASE
STEP FORWARD?
♪♪♪
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS GIRL
WILL STILL BE IN
THE RUNNING TOWARDS
BECOMING
AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND I WILL ONLY
CALL THAT NAME.
THE GIRL
THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BAGS,
AND GO HOME.
SARAH...
YOU'RE NOT STANDING THERE
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T WALK.
WE DON'T WANT
PERFECTION HERE.
WE WANT PALETTES THAT
WE CAN WORK WITH.
BUT WHEN WE SEE
SOMEBODY THAT
CRACKS UNDER PRESSURE,
THAT CAN'T HANDLE
A STUMBLE,
MAKES THESE
JUDGES BEHIND ME
WONDER, "CAN SHE HANDLE
THIS COMPETITION?"
ASHLEY.
IT'S INTERESTING
THAT YOU'RE
STANDING THERE AND
YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING,
"WHY THE HECK
AM I HERE?"
YOUR PICTURE
WAS ALL RIGHT.
YOUR RUNWAY WALK WAS
ALL RIGHT.
BUT THE JUDGES THINK,
"MAYBE SHE'S JUST
THE PRETTY GIRL
AND DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE
WHAT IT TAKES TO BE
A TOP MODEL."
♪♪♪
SARAH.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
AND WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA DO THE NEXT TIME
YOU STUMBLE ON
A RUNWAY?
'CAUSE THERE WILL BE
A NEXT TIME.
COMMAND
EVERYONE'S ATTENTION.
SAY,"THAT WAS ON
PURPOSE, Y'ALL."
YEAH.
- THANK YOU.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
THANKS, ASHLEY.
♪♪♪
YOU GUYS BEST MAKE
ME PROUD, YOU HEAR?
♪♪♪
YOU KNOW, TO BE, LIKE,
CRUSHED, IT SUCKS.
AND TO BE
CRUSHED FIRST SUCKS.
IF I TRY HARDER,
I WONDER WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN,
YOU KNOW?
WHAT'LL HAPPEN ON MY
SECOND CASTING CALL
IF THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENED ON MY FIRST?
THAT'S ALL I GOTTA
THINK ABOUT.
THERE CAN ONLY BE
ONE WINNER ANYWAYS.
THIS IS HOW IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE.
I'M NOT GONNA CRY.
NOT GONNA CRY.
YEAH.
♪♪♪